[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hey what is up everybody welcome back
to another Saturday morning 3D live
stream thank you all so much for joining
me I wasn't here last week I was taking
a break I was in Virginia at Camp
mograph chilling with other VFX artists
3D artists no computers we just had the
beach we had kayaks it was a beautiful
beautiful time I feel well rested I feel
ready to go for this stream so what are
we doing today what are we doing today
on this live stream so as a lot of you
probably already know
I hosted the fifth 3D Community
challenge a couple weeks ago August was
our working month and I challenged 3D
artists to create the coolest Tai Chi
inspired render uh given some provided
animations and a certain 3D prompt right
we put them all together we put together
this incredible top 100 Montage there's
an all renders Montage 3600 artists I
believe submitted to it with 24 years of
communal work
but we're talking the top 100 but
specifically the top five today the
artists who won this challenge are some
incredible artists
um they're very young artists they're
artists from around the world
um so I'm very very excited to bring
each one of them on today and talk with
them about their their workflows and how
they created their incredible renders
that won them this challenge out of 3
600 people only five
truly you know well I mean we're all
winners hey you know what I'm saying at
the end of the day we're all winners we
all put the work in we all did some cool
stuff over that month
um but these top five are incredible you
guys will see you've probably seen them
um if you hadn't buckle up there's some
really cool renders we're talking
workflows we're going to talk about what
inspired them to get started in 3D how
they learned
um and the cool thing about this is each
one of them have different answers to
these questions
so I hope that you guys can take all of
their knowledge and apply it to yourself
and learn something from each one of
these incredible artists that we're
going to bring on and talk to today
we're gonna do about 30 minutes which
eat with each one
um and we're gonna do a weekly challenge
review and I'll announce the winners for
this weekly challenge that we're doing
we're always doing challenges we're
always trying to push ourselves
um if you guys aren't part of the
Discord definitely click the link below
it's in the description join the Discord
get on the weekly challenges
um but before we bring on our first
guest our second place winner
um we got a little a word from the
sponsors today because you know that's
how I keep these things going that's how
I keep this channel up and running so I
thank you for your time thank you for
your patience I'm glad you all are here
grab a drink buckle up it's gonna be a
good time
uh two minutes word from the sponsor and
I'll see you guys back with our first
guest all right all right see you soon
today's sponsor is an interesting one
but a very important one for men out
there experiencing hair loss two out of
three men will experience male pattern
baldness by the age of 35. and signs of
hair loss can creep in as early as 20.
unfortunately it is a thing that most of
us will have to deal with but lucky for
us keeps is the sponsor of today's video
keeps is a subscription based service
that helps men keep their hair their
treatments are clinically proven and
research-backed of course and delivered
straight to your door at about half the
price of a traditional Pharmacy each
personalized treatment plan comes with a
full year of unlimited messaging and
individual support from keeps this vast
network of Expert Medical advisors
prescribers and Care Specialists who
will help you select the right product
for your specific situation keeps also
offers an award-winning all-natural
shampoo and conditioner to keep your
head fresh on The Daily so whether
you're looking to prevent hair loss
stimulate hair growth or just take
better care of the hair that you have
keeps has got you covered to get 50
percent off your first order go to
keeps.com Punisher that is
k-e-e-p-s.com slash pwn i s h e r
yo
what is hey what's up
hey how you doing
yeah I'm doing great man what about you
oh I'm chilling man I'm chilling it's a
good time we got your beautiful art
playing here crushing it I don't believe
that I'm here like with Punisher the
double Punisher
YouTube Legend
dude it was funny man one time we were
playing Airsoft and like it was me Sam
and Nico and
we were like loading out our gear and
stuff and uh there was these little kids
like off to the right in the other
corner of this like staging room
and they start they were like Whispering
amongst themselves and I was like oh
excuse me to one of the kids because I
was like moving by and his friend was
like that's the Punisher here talking to
I was like do did you just say that what
the heck that's so weird
anyway man we're here about you today
man um can you introduce yourself and
where where are you from as well
okay so my name is shuparno uh my actual
name like my actually Mr porno but my
nickname is Zeus uh actually the zoo's
name comes from uh the game Age of
Mythology if you have played it
I really love that game like I used to
play it with the god Zeus all the time
so I just uh iterated that name from him
I guess
and okay so I am from Kolkata uh uh
Kolkata West Bengal India
so it's uh called the city of Joy
basically it's a lovely city uh in the
eastern part of India
and there I was I have been pulled by
air my whole life so and now I'm just uh
creating 3D art you know but uh so my
journey right so I actually am an
engineer so I'm an I.T engineer
uh I actually studied Bachelor's in
information technology
and after that I actually got a job as
well but uh I actually did not take the
job I thought that taking up a job would
just mean like ending my creativity to
be honest oh man okay so that's huge
right there how so how many years did
you go to school
uh
so uh uh so 12 so class 12th so
basically 15 years right there and then
after that uh
I added four years of college
yeah
how
how I'm 26. okay okay
what did your parents think like what
what did you have to tell your parents
were they cool with that like I'm sure
you know that's tough I'm sure a lot of
people are relate to you as well right
now
so yeah it's a fun story like I was
actually gaming during my college Years
so about four years I uh used to game a
lot and I really became good at one game
in particular so that was DotA 2. I know
one of the mods also played uh also
plays MDK he plays DOTA DOTA 2. that's
awesome yeah so so yeah I actually
became like uh you can see a
professional literally because I used to
just play uh that game all day long
during my college Years okay okay so I
reached around top 300 in Southeast Asia
in that game right and then uh I I like
I have already participated in a lot of
tournaments during the years like 2015
to 2018
and when I graduated from college I
thought that why not try and pursue this
get this as a career
so I tried Competitive Gaming as a
career you know for about
two years I guess yeah what did your
family think are you really supportive
of you or were they like
uh my brother was really supportive
that's why I could continue otherwise it
was not possible like they were
absolutely not uh with it at all they
were totally against it you know India
you just become an engineer or doctor
first and then you decide what to do
with life that's the first step it's
like first you got to be a doctor or an
engineer and then we'll go from there
yeah yeah exactly that's crazy so yeah
you know it's I think it's similar a lot
of us 3D artists are in the our Gamers
ourselves
um myself included I have loved games
ever since I think my the first time I
touched a game was the Game Boy Color
uh I remember like in church one of the
one of the kids had a Game Boy Color and
I was like and then I think I got one
like close to that point and I just
remember playing like army men games and
uh Mario Kart and eventually got
PlayStation one and of course it went
all the way to the point you know we're
at PlayStation 5 now which is insane but
yeah a lot of the inspiration comes from
games too yeah I also wanted a Game Boy
but yeah I couldn't have voted at that
point and my parents didn't want to give
it to me so yeah I just had to settle
for a PC I didn't really get a console
anytime so all my life I've been a PC
Gamer that's awesome yeah same my dad
like he would he one of his Hobbies was
building computers and stuff and he kind
of taught me a little bit about it um so
we always had like he was always gaming
in the house and stuff and what's cool
is like when you have a pretty decent PC
for games that means you kind of have a
decent PC for 3D you know yeah exactly
they go hand in hand
um so I gotta ask all right this what
the art we're looking at right here
right we did this challenge in August
you had a month to create this
um how long had you been working in 3D
before uh this art we're seeing right
here
yeah so I actually started 3D around
December 2020 so that's the first time
I've opened up blender that's the first
program I opened up in 3D so fun story
is that uh I wouldn't have opened up 3D
but uh in around December my previous PC
that is a GTX 1070 PC that actually
broke down so I had to get a new one so
I thought you know there's the new
latest generation 3000 Series cards and
let's just get the 3080 I just told my
brother maybe let's just try to Source
it Finance it somehow and get it uh so
just for playing games honestly yeah
playing games
uh and then I got it and then suddenly I
saw that there is a thing called 3D I
was actually doing some photoshop work
at that time like photo manipulation
and then I was having a lot of trouble
with finding good source photos to use
uh for my photo manipulations and I
thought let's just try 3D and maybe I
can make my own assets and use them for
photo manipulation so that's where I
really started I started with the
blender Guru donut tutorial
that's the that's so many That's a
classic yeah yeah I finished it around a
week in another week and then I got so
tired of blender I was like okay that's
it I'm totally burnt out let's just go
back to photoshop with my old ways and
yeah uh I just gave up for about a month
I can't hear you
yeah hello yeah I got you you're here
right yeah yeah so you got burnt out
from blender yeah yeah I got burned out
only and then I took a month break so
the break was uh literally me working in
Photoshop just making photo manipulation
images artworks like that yeah they were
really bad you can even see them right
now if you go down my Instagram posts
they're still there I don't want to
remove them actually no you gotta
remember where you came from yeah you
gotta remember where you came from yeah
um yeah so two things in February I just
uh you know okay what I was gonna say
that um for those of you who want to
follow
um uh porno's work it is linked in the
description I think I got your art
station down there but maybe that'll
link to like other things perhaps um or
Zeus creates yeah go by Zeus creates as
well
um underscore creates everywhere yeah
only on YouTube it's Zeus space creates
um so just just for for everyone's info
following this right now we got all the
winners info linked down below
um but I'm blown away that you've only
been in 3D for two years man that's
crazy like we see people in the chat
here and like they're like what two
years only it's crazy so you guys
started during covet right
yeah yeah all that time yes see y'all
that this is what happens when you apply
yourself when you got some free time
okay you're like what the heck am I
gonna do I have all this free time
um let's learn something awesome and man
yeah
yeah a lot of us were man a lot of us I
was kind of lost as well what to do with
life so you know I was just trying out
stuff the Photoshop I started because of
uh Benny Productions I I think a lot of
people might know that channel it's
about 7 million Subs I think right now
is that on uh Instagram like it's just
like little Photoshop tutorials right
yeah Photoshop tutorials yeah we got it
with Photoshop yeah yeah and then I
branched out to 3D around that time
December uh January to January of 2021
that that area yeah
yeah so I I mean dude I saw your your
um infinite Journeys render that's the
that's six months before this okay this
is six months ago seven months ago when
we did our second to last 3D Challenge
and like you've come such a long way man
it's so cool to see
um I wanna so I want to get into this
art right everyone's probably wondering
like how do you go about creating this
what is your personal approach to
getting started with a scene like this
like
what when when the challenge was
announced right and you saw all these
um Tai Chi mocap files
where did your brain start going like
how did you start coming up with ideas
what's your process for coming up with
ideas
so uh the challenge just got announced
and I saw all the different mocap
animations available like 27 28 of them
yeah and I was really overwhelmed
totally like I was thinking that uh how
do I even come up with an idea when I
have so many ideas available in front of
me
and then uh I just went into art station
and Pinterest tried to search for ideas
and see if there's anything that strike
that struck me instantly I tried to see
all the ideas that other people have
just random visuals there's uh like no
idea at that point
and then I was browsing uh even discard
like what discussion people were having
with each other however they're thinking
about this Challenge and then I uh found
out about Prisma so I wanted to give him
a shout out here as well uh he actually
helped me a lot in this challenge like a
lot of feedback from him uh it wouldn't
have been possible without him to be
honest his feedback was invaluable to me
wow so that's awesome shout outs yeah so
I uh went into his art station and then
I saw his Coco breakdown by the way I
can show it right now if you want yeah
you switch over breakdown
yeah are you seeing it right now
yeah so this is the breakdown that he
made so the actual image that he made
this is not from the movie the movies
down below I think yes this is this is
his and this is the reference
do you oh wow so it's like yes
no like it looks like he was doing a
study right trying to study to see yeah
yeah to recreate studies yeah and this
is where I got the idea of the attic
from I thought let's just watch the
movie first and then yeah see how Pixar
does their lighting and stuff and from
there I got the idea of the Attic So I
have also
yeah yeah so this is the inspiration
that I have uh
I basically found it from here so I
watched Coco and then came back and I
thought let's just make an attic scene
like this so with candles and uh with
candles lighting and a TV somewhere yeah
this is my idea that
and
I can show you the concept as well
yeah absolutely absolutely so this is a
great Lookout that they made
yeah it's just really important you know
it's really important to
yeah to have a direction like you know
yeah it's really important I have been
participating in these challenges uh
since around 2021 uh the alternate
realities won and uh yeah I did not
really do uh such a concept before so I
think if this was very new new to me as
well yeah so this is the concept that I
have so everything is uh like the ideas
are there but the uh the the placements
are just weird right like this uh areas
like I have the items that I want but uh
the placements are just off by a lot
okay the basic idea to go with I think
yeah yeah so basically you did a block
out you knew that your room was going to
be about that shape and you are in
blender is that correct
yes yes awesome you make a lot of people
happy in the chat
blender the blender cult is happy yeah
so you did a block out
um you found your animation you kind of
got like a basic lighting set up and
then you're going in and you're going to
photoshop or whatever and you're just
gonna sketching in Photoshop ideas and
exploring ideas my sketching is really
bad but it does the job you know yeah
yeah exactly exactly yeah this is
basically the idea that I had at first
and after that I can show you the
test
oh yeah bring it on
okay
this is the basic scene okay this is the
first uh after the concept I did this
uh I just uh
put put on put some other objects in the
scene and try to see how the scene will
look with these
and then I went ahead and even refined
it further just you can see everything
just changing image by image
yeah I just put in some random images
here I think I got it from envato
elements and just try to see if these
work
and then after that
I tried some different lighting as well
yeah you can see the TV uh the backlit
TV this is basically the same as Coco
in my reference
can you hear me yeah mm-hmm
yeah can you hear me
yeah yeah you got yeah I think yeah I
got you yeah I got you yeah yeah
okay so after that uh I just keep going
and adding details and just refining the
lighting further and further you can see
just uh in this one
it's just backlit I was thinking of
going the same direction as Coco
that they had in the scene just a bit a
bigger scene not as cramped as that one
so you're like it's it's tough what
you're doing because like to to Really
build out your scene you just have to
add a ton of stuff and it's not gonna
feel right
and filled in until you have a ton of
stuff it's gonna feel empty like for so
long like how long did your scene feel
empty before you knew like okay yeah
this is really nice
it was very long like it was always
looking empty I was always thinking like
what sort of stuff can I add so that it
looks better uh it's basically said
dressing so I had to think of a lot of
stuff I had to basically think that uh
what does the kid do what does the kid
have what does his parents have in the
Attic uh water is what are his current
interests these are the questions that
you need to ask yourself so I've also
written these in the same in this R
station breakdown uh addressing part I
think it's down here somewhere
it's a beautiful breakdown too if you
guys have a chance to take a look at it
after after the stream here like or you
know just pull up alongside it's like
it's really well if I lose something
it's probably here yeah if I miss
something here yeah you can see just uh
just go through this breakdown it's
mostly here
I think that's a great thing though is
like character and how character can
build out your scene in your story and
you have to ask yourself like yeah what
is this character into if you're putting
together like a character's bedroom or
in this case a character's attic you
have to put stuff up there that you know
fits the character and if it just seems
like a bunch of random stuff you know
you're gonna miss out so keep going
please yeah I'm so interested in like in
this process yeah yeah so yeah I'm just
uh adding random stuff here just trying
to figure out what works and what
doesn't uh you can see the disc behind
the character this is very small right
now
it's like the scale is totally off right
now so uh these are the things that even
prismal pointed out to me so this is why
it's very important to get some feedback
from others because you can always miss
stuff like this like the scale being off
or some random light not working uh
these are the bigger picture things I
think you need help with sometimes when
you're working with a big project
sometimes you just miss these stuff so
uh always try to get someone to get
someone to look at your stuff so you can
see the the tables look so weird right
it looks like a table for I don't know
for dwarfs maybe yeah I don't know yeah
so after that you can see these chair
and the stool that I have they are too
big for the scene but I was just way too
focused on trying to correct the
lighting I didn't really pay attention
to them but slowly and slowly the scene
developed I tried different lighting uh
different types of lighting
and then yeah this is uh the place where
it's all coming together almost
uh the lighting is at least yeah I
thought that the TV was not working in
the background so I just placed to the
right
it's nice yeah the frames it kind of
frames yeah it just yeah it just looks
uh it just takes away attention I think
that in this one like if the TV is just
behind him it's just a bit too
distracting so that's why I uh put it to
the right here because it balances it
out as well yeah
yeah I tried some different lighting
from the TV
uh this purple lighting was not working
I just tried it in case it worked
a lot of trial and error at this point
really I think that's good though
because like to to touch on what you
said about trying that purple but it
totally didn't work like the but what if
it did right so you you would never know
if it works or not unless you try it and
I think one thing that's very important
here with with all of our art is that if
you have a goal in mind and I think I've
talked about this before but you have a
clear direction from the beginning right
you had your attic scene you had the
Coco style
um you know set up and
um you you have a pretty good idea of
where you're going and if you head in
that direction and you blindly go in
that direction like you might be missing
all of these awesome turn offs that will
make your art so much cooler in the end
and there's no way to like
discover those awesome turn offs well
turn off is probably not the best word
to use but you know what I'm saying like
it's an alternate path right yeah yeah
um exactly you have to try it so so much
of 3D is trial and error so it's cool to
see you doing that here as you're
creating you're seeing what works what
doesn't and you're just you know feeling
out the vibe the whole time
yeah it's like happy little accidents
you know like Bob Ross says you have to
do stuff and sometimes there are happy
little accidents along the way
eventually
yeah yeah but keep going yeah keep going
yeah okay so this is the Zen table that
I added I thought that this character's
feet was sliding a bit and I didn't
really want to go through the effort of
fixing it so I just added this uh it
works with the scene I think so that's
perfect yeah it's perfect
yeah it's a very uh dirty fix but it's
it's works I guess
yeah I also by the way TV the TV is
actually a model from an image I have
shown it here as well that
there's this yeah this is the image and
I just used Ian Hubert's technique that
is image plane modeling
ah yeah so good this is the final TV
yeah I didn't want to waste time on this
like modeling it perfectly since it's a
background asset so I just modeled it
together very fast it looks perfect man
like it's such a yeah such a great
technique man thank thank God for Ian
Hubert I think all of us can see it
exactly exactly
okay so I'll just quickly go through
these yeah
we got another 15 minutes or so yeah
yeah yeah yeah so I added this as well
the secret Dojo thing uh as a Tory gate
this was my plan all along to add a sort
of story gate to unite the foreground
and background
before going to Mid ground uh so that
when the camera moves back you just see
this thing it just adds a layer of depth
I guess that's why you added it totally
and there's some story in there too
yeah yeah exactly
then I just kept adding stuff trying
different basically adding lots of stuff
right now because there's not much to
talk about I added my old art here as
well like my alternate realities under
the infinite Journeys the what is this
uh the dynamic machines one oh my God
those were just Easter eggs that's
awesome Easter eggs
yeah
this is where the test renders end I
have more I think
this is a character test
how long did you spend on the character
versus the environment
um
character I think I this challenge I
think I finished the character very
early because I thought that last
challenge I left it for too late so I
didn't really spend too much I think I
just used it as character and from there
I created very basic clothes in
Marvelous Designer the only thing that
caused me issues was the animation it
was clipping a lot yeah the animation
that number 22 22 animation so I had
actually uh done a few little tests
where I was trying to fix the character
a lot but I finally managed to do it
these are the different I had and I was
even trying the other animation this was
easier
uh there were there was not much
clipping but I thought that if I didn't
fix this then uh I would be defeated I
really need to fix this myself uh
instead of just going with an easier
animation yeah that I had to go into the
graph editor manually and fix it and
then do the clothes Sim
it took a little bit of time but not
much honestly
that's good man and then most of the
time was spent in environment design
yeah
into what
oh I lost you again
yeah yeah there you go hey gotcha got
you yeah
okay so we can go into the lighting
maybe the lighting part yeah let's take
a look take a look at the final let's
take a look at the final images
um Soto if you want to switch over to my
screen perhaps we can just take a look
at this final like I I think this is
incredible it's you have
talk about lighting right you have all
of these
like
man it's just great yeah it's all these
different little pools of light that are
perfectly placed to make
um the contrast
shine man like you're really
highlighting the character here the lamp
it all feels natural I think that's the
thing is it feels natural yeah
um yeah I had to add these practical
lights the lamp the TV and the lamb
above doors are the main light sources
yeah
yep and then you kind of just like well
let's get into it yeah let's switch back
and like let's see let's see how you set
up your lighting for this because I'm
very curious
relax
oops Yeah hey we got you yeah
yeah uh so the uh my scene my final
scene
uh as you can see and then
camera everything is in front only the
other part behind the camera there is
nothing because yeah I don't want to
waste my time
uh and then this is my
yeah this is my background Point lights
so these can
oh we lost you again audio
you got you
it's going in and out
yeah yeah can you hear yeah
yeah okay so these down Point lights
that you're seeing so these are
basically uh for the candles that I have
on the scene so these are flickering
flickering a little bit uh I just use
the graph editor I have on my R station
by the way if anyone wants to know how I
did it uh so yeah uh they're just uh
plugged into a noise modifier and
they're just flickering around a little
bit they're just offset a little bit
here and there so that it doesn't look
all the same and it gives that candle
flickering effect
so that is the background lighting yeah
so it's just the candles
yeah but just the candles always
literally all of the point lights
yeah amazing
and now
I just
seen uh and and these are some rim
lights that I added
these are some
yeah hello
hello what it is
yeah can you hear me
I got nothing
no I can't hear
yeah get can you hear me now
well if I can't hear him
I got I got soda Monte okay I got
sodomontay in one ear I got Zeus crates
in another ear
so I can't hear it this way yeah I've
lost you bud I can't hear you
still got nothing
what is happening I'm not sure I got
nothing
um
yeah so these are the rim lights that I
have uh this this lamp is actually doing
a
Life Source
yeah
yeah
these are the rim lights that I have
it's not happening can you guys hear me
in the Stream
they're saying don't move
hey Zeus go back to like your our
station page or something
okay
does this work okay I still can't hear
you
should I close my blender scene
okay
all right so it looks like they can hear
you
some people can hear something you can't
they're saying don't move the scene it
interrupts the Stream
should I just close the screen I
it's hungry
they can hear you but this is
an interview
well let's see we got we got another
seven seven minutes or so
um
Zeus can you hear me
yeah yeah I can hear
that's so funny okay
[Laughter]
uh
huh what
thank you
dude this is hilarious
where is it
on the screen on the screen
oh yeah
where there's some backwards like you
guys have seen the inner workings here
of the Stream
Lots going on here
yeah all right so what's going on
sodomontay are you going to translate
into my ear
foreign
lots of area lights around the lamp and
the main lamp as well so uh those are
just lighting up the entire mid ground
section uh I have this uh area here see
uh character and dog lighting rims with
practical Lights accentuated by fake
lights so these are basically fake
lights uh the lamp is doing nothing but
the fake lights are the one that is
lighting this uh mid-ground area to be
honest and then some rim lights for the
Zen table clothes as well the sun table
cloth and Zen stones
um and there are some more Point lights
for the mid-ground bulb
wouldn't uh
that call I'm not sure wouldn't think
I'm not sure what they're called rough
yeah so and then uh here are the point
lights uh they are just tiny bulbs
just tiny Point lights for those tiny
bulbs near the Tory gate that I have and
then there is an entire fill light for
Christmas lights
yeah
and then I have this fill light for the
entire scene so that everything just
doesn't go to uh just go to Every just
so that everything just doesn't go to
the black uh section so that I have some
level of
um what is what to say
light there is
yeah and these are the candles you can
see everything uh the sculpted candle a
flame emission plane and a point light
for those
a simple wax material
but I'm not gonna risk it if
yeah if the stream crashes or something
yeah it's this is the layer stack I
think you can see it I'm not sure
yeah it doesn't doesn't zoom in
so this is the main raw render that I
had and this is the compositing hey Zeus
blender try closing blender
okay
yeah all right I closed it no
is that any better
no still nothing
it's okay all right so here we're gonna
have to do
the the this blind interview we're gonna
wrap this up we got two more minutes
anyway it's all good until we get our
next guest so
um yeah
if you guys want to check out more of
Zeus's stuff his art station is linked
in the description
um go check it out dig into this
breakdown he's obviously as you can see
he got a lot of cool stuff a lot of
detail that went into this breakdown
um congratulations again man thank you
so much for for coming on and doing this
and for second place it's been an honor
huge man you've come such a long way
absolutely man yeah you've come such a
long way since all of these challenges
you've been doing every single one of
these challenges and like it's so cool
to see you progress through each one of
those
um even through the weekly challenges
it's such a freaking awesome cool thing
to see so thank you thank you thank you
so much thank you for doing this for
putting the work together thank you for
doing these challenges
thank you for doing these challenges
absolutely sorry absolutely I will talk
to you soon but uh guys we're gonna hit
our next uh artist here okay uh coming
up thank you Zeus appreciate you man
yeah good stuff later all right goodbye
bye-bye
who's this
who we got
to meet you where are you at
hi Dimitri
I'm here you're here hello yep uh uh
levels peaking I see red
let me get a little audio test Dimitri
um
hello
yeah what's interesting time
I'll get there we'll get there yeah
welcome
um let me get your art pulled up on the
screen here for you
um because it is some incredible I can
also open it myself I heard prepared
um Dimitri hey man welcome
congratulations how are you doing today
um I'm doing good
awesome man awesome awesome
um congratulations your art freaking so
nice man you got uh third place in the
challenge
um the internet not infinite Journeys
what am I saying the movie meditations
3D challenge absolutely beautiful scene
I love the darkness of it I love like
the the design elements going on here
these 2D elements
um Sunburst back here very very filmic
man so let me let me start with uh how
did you get started in 3D like um can
you tell me a little bit about yourself
a little bit of background for everyone
here
well I started started learning 3D like
only two years ago but before that
actually it was always interested in
filmmaking so I already had experience
before that uh I was like
I was like to see a movie first and then
to see a like BTS breakdown of all the
scenes how they set up a green screen
and how they explained how they did all
the shots and VFX it was always super
interesting for me even like since my
childhood
and originally I started doing some
simple videos with my friends in Windows
Movie Maker then I switched to the Sony
Vegas and then I started learning After
Effects back when I was like 12 I think
it was like 10 years ago so I already
had some experience before even before
3D
uh so yeah it was a little easier to get
good looking image from from yeah only
two years of experience I think um we
started very very similarly I started
out filming little silly videos with my
friends using Windows Movie Maker
um because it is free it comes with your
computer and um you know I think being a
fan of movies
is you know like you have a background
of references in your mind and you know
shots you know angles you know lighting
you maybe don't know it know it but you
can you can see it in your head you
remember it from the movies that you saw
and I think you know having
a a list of of references like that
watching a bunch of movies playing a
bunch of games like are you a gamer at
already playing games yeah I play a lot
of games
yeah yeah that's awesome
my favorite games of they're so serious
serious and you can probably see it in
my artwork the inspiration
what would you say what Games inspired
this art if any
um mostly it was dark souls and
bloodborne oh dude those are just some
of the best masterpiece
ah man
yeah it's that lighting man that blue
dark lighting is incredible so you said
you guys started two years ago and what
program are you in
I'm using blender
more love for the blender yes I love it
man it makes sense like if you guys are
starting
uh in 3D these days like it's free right
so it's the most accessible I would say
and obviously you can see here that you
can do Top Notch work with it
um so there's no reason not to to dive
in
um did you also get started in 3D during
covid
yeah I believe that was around that time
I saw that in Herbert was doing his
latest tutorials back then so that was
where I started from trying to repeat
his tutorials
amazing man amazing
do you have a group of friends in your
area
um that you could like sync up with and
show stuff with or was it just more on
the internet more on like Discord yeah I
have a bunch of artists friends and we
always share knowledge with each other
and
trying to learn blender together
that's great man I think it's very
important to have a network of people of
friends that can help push each other
for this kind of stuff
um all right so let's get into it man
uh once the challenge was announced
how did you go about coming up with an
idea
um usually I would try to find some
references and maybe do a simple sketch
but this time the process was a little
a little different so
here I can show you on my screen the
first render I did from the
um for the render
um yeah we see so cool I'll only knew
that I wanted to make uh some sort of
desert scene in the night and with a big
planet in the background and the first
idea I got from looking at all the
animations was that I wanted to make
some magic
circles going on at like some runes
behind the character uh I just wanted to
learn how to do magic prefix this time
for the um during this challenge so this
was the very first render from the scene
that they got uh it's really simple the
background mountains are just made with
the default blender add-on for creating
Landscapes I don't remember how it's
called but it was just for the like as a
placeholder
so the first thing I did then was I
decided to add the texture at least to
the ground so
because I needed to start somewhere so
uh for this texture I used uh textures
from quixon Mega scans and mix a bunch
of mod texture and quick saw mixer to
get this uh texture that wouldn't look
too
repeated on the ground
but yeah pretty much covered everything
with rocks so you don't even see it in
the final video
so question you right now at this point
you're
you're kind of blocking out your
lighting you're blocking out your scene
are you working off of any reference do
you have a reference board or are you
just off the top of your head on this
uh this time I didn't have any
references but usually I try to
figure to find figure the final image
before I start and
I try to imagine the final look of the
image before I even start doing it but
this time I was just kind of
um create creating uh whatever ideas I
get along the way so so you're just kind
of at this point in play kind of mode
just experiment yeah this time I didn't
even know that I would add the ruins uh
and the scene I just didn't know how it
will end up looking at the end
wow so you're truly just like
flying free and coming up with what's
cool how many how many days like do you
give yourself like okay after X amount
of days
I gotta be at a certain point in my
render or yeah a schedule for this or
are you just like you know caution to
the win I'm just going for it
actually I saw a tutorial for that in
your Discord server some I don't
remember who posted that Connor yeah
it's Connor yeah yeah I I just used that
to roughly imagine where it should be at
the end of each week
okay okay all right so continue yeah
this is awesome
okay so here I replace the mountains in
the background with this uh like weird
pointy shapes uh which are kind of flat
on top to make those I used a program
called
I don't know how how it's pronounced but
yeah yeah
this one uh it's a program where you can
generate landscapes
really easily from noise and I just use
the default preset for this kind of
desert looking Hill and change the the
settings bunch of times to get different
looking mountains
oh nice here I was just adding more and
more Mountains and at this point what
I'm trying to get is
I'm looking at leading lines I'm already
starting to think about composition
right here you can see that the biggest
mountains are on the sides and as I get
closer to the middle they are getting
smaller so we get kind of those diagonal
lines towards the character which
believe your eye towards the center of
the image and I will repeat the same
thing all over
again during
later steps with even smaller assets
so here I was just messing with the
roughness of the ground and with light
I specifically made the mod a little
more
shiny as they usually light like night
scenes in the movie you know like how
they would wet so it would reflect the
lighting and it just looks
yeah yeah that was what I was trying to
make here
so right here I didn't know what right
on the sides and it looked really empty
and boring at this point so I added a
couple of heels on size and they also
created those leading lines toward the
center they kind of create this visual
vignette
on screen
yeah I found that that's like a really
nice way to well of course right when we
talk about vignettes we're talking about
just darkening the edges of the frame to
kind of
draw the eye to the center of the photo
or the or the image right and you could
do that you I mean I'd do it on pretty
much every single one of my renders is
all crank the vignette so it really
focuses it on the center composition but
another thing you can do is
you can get tricky with it and you can
naturally vignette your scene or your
character and yeah Dimitri that's what
you're talking about right now is using
these mountains to naturally make the
edges darker
um and kind of direct the light to the
character in The foreground I think
that's it's I love seeing natural
vignettes it's amazing it's so nice
and they also make the composition easy
to understand you're just immediately
immediately look at the image and see
the main part of the image uh when your
when you have a bunch of leading lines
the frame so at this point I added a
bunch of these
like wooden poles all over this in the
country one may remind me of medieval
times and you always see something like
that and there are souls games
they are made just from Pixel Bridge
assets uh stuck together oh okay so
you're gonna keep bashing these things
they look real yeah
and those dudes are just a zombie model
from mix Summer
so yeah nothing complicated
that's great and here I here I was
adding a bunch of trees in the
background and you don't even see them
in the final image that's that's my
biggest problem I always do a lot of
work that that's unnecessary that I will
hide in the final image and it takes a
lot of time to add those details I need
to figure out a better way of working
someday oh man you and I both like I
yeah I'm I'm a sucker for that I really
tried to avoid that on my last piece of
art here for this challenge
um because I remember during infinite
Journeys when I was making my like race
car cockpit scene and I was modeling all
these details and I talk about the idea
that I was kind of I was like running
away from the work I knew that needed to
be done that was kind of a little scary
namely the character working on my
character
um and I was doing things that like
were just fun for me which was modeling
um and adding detail but at the end I
just wasted so much time on it um
and it it really stopped me from
pushing the art as far as it could have
gone so it's good that you recognize
that I think it's something that we're
all trying to
to work on we want to work as
efficiently as possible obviously and
like
you know but sometimes when you're
creating art
you know efficiency isn't the first
thing you can't just be efficient you do
need to like do some trial and error and
and work on some stuff and see how
things look but I I think you know
you're talking about the trees here that
you put all these trees in are the trees
in this image right here or are they in
the previous one
um boss here in previous one I just was
moving them around
yeah okay so you got some shrubs you got
some like trees in the far back I mean
they look really nice I think if I was
at your point in the process like
I would I would have thought those trees
are awesome and they do look awesome I
mean I would just keep going on on the
process here so at this point
in your process you're building it out
you're finding your scene
how do you how do you feel about it
right now if you can imagine yourself a
month and a half ago at this point in
the process
at this point I still didn't like what I
was getting because it was still too
empty and I I wasn't sure if I'll get a
nice looking image in the end I didn't
know how much details
I'll need to add in the future but then
um it was all good when I started adding
a bunch of rocks in the foreground
right here uh I started adding little
rocks and maybe it was too early but
there were all composition was kinda
already in its place so I decided to
start adding a bunch of little details
all over the place
okay starting to get nice
yeah I was just adding more and more
rocks all over the place that's all from
quixel bridge
oh and even here I'm still trying to
maintain the leading lines on the sides
even though I'm covering the hill I'm
still trying to make this diagonal light
line be visible
and here I simplify the shape of the
mountain so it would both look Giant and
also would create a really simple shape
with a leading lies line towards the
center
this is this is freaking beautiful I
gotta stop you here I'm gonna I mean
that's that's my job I'm just gonna stop
you and keep asking questions so
like where where are you learning
composition where are you learning
lighting is it just from watching movies
and being like I like that movie and I'm
gonna try and like reference that or or
like
you know uh are you watching tutorials
on YouTube what are you doing to learn
uh I'm watching tutorials on YouTube and
also before I started doing 3D I started
learning concept art and how to like
draw into the in Photoshop so I was
watching a lot of tutorials about that
about drawing and doing concept art in
general so that was where I learned a
lot more about uh composition and
the color theory in general
now are these like paid services or this
is just YouTube like concept mostly it's
just free tutorials on YouTube
actually a really nice idea is is
watching tutorials on concept design
concept art environmental concept art I
never even thought of that because I
just assumed like I know what I know and
what I know is good enough when it comes
to composition like I know some tricks
but
of course we're all trying to learn and
grow our bag of tools right so that's
not a bad idea is to dive into some cons
environmental concept tutorials that's
pretty sweet you might have to do that
okay continue please yeah I'm loving
this um here on the right side I was
getting this weird shape with a bunch of
mountains and didn't like it because it
just seemed to
broken down and random and ugly I wanted
to make to simplify it later so
uh a bit later I'll change it to just
one continuous shape of a mountain
Hero's just messing with some grass and
adding more rocks and then here you can
see I'm still adding those leading lines
this rock is a little bigger and this
one is smaller everything in the shot
should make little leading lines towards
the center
anyone here is this rock
everything is purposeful man I love it
and this was where I added those like uh
sculptures or I don't know how to call
them just that people made of stone uh
so powerful it looks so good
yeah
I I don't remember where I got this
reference but it just reminds me of Dark
Souls so I decided to do it here that's
a good enough reason
um
and even with those starters so as you
can see I'm still making those leading
lines towards the center and I will
shape them even more later so here was
where I decided that
it has a lot of empty space on top so I
wanted to make some simple structures
with a really readable shapes
uh like those arches so I might just use
the the cubes this thing first
and then I replaced it with ruins made
in 3D code 3D code is really useful for
making
those kind of this kind of ruins really
quickly 3D and you 3D code here I'll
show you 3D code you can do everything
the same in blender and in zbrush but I
just don't know how to do it in there so
I decided to learn a completely new
program just drawings amazing but it
works amazing also I recorded a small
demonstration
um yesterday so to do a simple essays
like this for example this wall
first thing you need to do find this
tutorial three code base Explorer
concept art by Art of just Vega on
YouTube it's one hour long and it
explains everything into though
everything
um like everything you need to know
about uh basic tools to make the
simplest Assets in here
and the second thing you need to do is
go to our station and find RX Pi profile
he has two really cool packs of stencils
on
Marketplace stencils are these black and
white textures that you can use to
create a lot of details really quickly
this whole wall of bricks was made just
with a texture like this so
I overlay this
um image on top
and just use a bib to
adjust in one click I create a lot of
details like this just from a texture
heck yeah and this is that's why the 3D
code is really powerful you can
create really detailed assets really
quickly here I'm overlaying this uh like
mod or rocket texture on top and a
couple of clicks I'm adding a lot of
details all over the place
that's awesome
and then I would export this model to
blender 3D and or I mean UV unwrap it
with just a default tools like smart EV
project
and then then I would import it to
substance painter and just to mess with
smart materials a little bit
uh
and then just couple of clicks I'll get
this really cool looking detailed asset
and then I'll just import all the
textures in blender and here only like
in 20 minutes yesterday I made this wall
so yeah 3 code is really powerful for
creating such stuff thank you yeah good
to know
so that's how you're doing the stuff on
the left and the right yeah it's
architectural a little bits sweet okay
so then I was just
into more details also I added these
like Circle
um
stuff
um right here I just wanted to make this
feel uh make this place feel like a some
old Temple so I'm adding
more uh elements to the ground
like this one
here I'm added a bunch of tiles and put
them on the size
and also you can see here that I put the
guys in a really simple arrow shape
there
that uh which is pointing to the center
and so is here on the right side
and that was
almost everything for the 3D bar here's
just a
red painting in the background for the
character I just used the character
model I already had on my PC for from uh
from an old project which we were
working on is my friend
so I didn't do much stuff for the
character this time only simulated the
clothes in Marvel's designer
okay for so for the matte painting we
will show you
this was the matte painting I made in
Photoshop I just rendered the very first
frame of the sequence and painted on top
of it
you painted wait how'd you do those
clouds was that a brush or is that just
like oh because it just hand painted it
took the whole day to paint this thing
with different brushes what but you
painted those
yeah good good
dude it looks that's why you need to
start from uh learning how to draw just
to do with paintings what the heck
wow what about the sky is that hdri did
you paint that too
um
um before that you can see right here
this guy was just in jirai ahead on my
PC and it just kind of referenced it in
terms or in in terms of color to make
this one here it just it was just a
solid layer for the background with uh
star Stars photo correlate on top and
uh also for the reference I used
these shots from edin these concept Arts
I really like the color and the how they
Light the Night scene
so I was referencing that for the mid
painting
beautiful I love your scene like I would
love to explore this world the lighting
is thank you I love blue hour man like
right before right when the Sun goes
down and there's just a little bit left
in the sky like you have here so like
where the highlight of the sky the
yellow of the sky meets the clouds was
that painted or was that an image uh
that was the image okay okay it's a
combination of uh images and like hand
painting
so good
what I did then was I separated this
whole image in separate layers and put
them into the actual or projected the
images on actual planes in 3D scene so
when the camera would move in the video
so you would see a little bit of
distortion in there but you still can't
can't see it in the final video so I'm
still doing a lot of unnecessary work
here you can see some some process I I
had three layers in 3D but then I
rendered them into only two images just
so it would be easier for compositing I
didn't need the third layer I just
needed it to move properly in the frame
I see so you're just trying to get some
Parallax when you zoom
yeah okay so here I'll show you my
process that I had after I finished the
uh everything in 3D so I had two passes
like this
this was the background where I later
put an explosion this was a little
closer
also I had two smoke layers I made this
smoke uh volumetric smoke in ambergen
it's a just default preset of some dust
or sand amazing stuff like that I just
sticked it a little bit and put directly
to blender
um
so here are other this was the
foreground bus also had two passes for
I mean misspass I needed two of them
just to get a little more resolution or
like color depth here yes uh I use I use
this pass uh to blend 3D layer to matte
painting right here I messed this part
to blend softly from 3D stuff to the
painting in the background so now we're
talking compositing all right so you
have your final render and you're doing
this what in After Effects
yep okay all right so you exported your
file these are these would be image
sequences right
um you could be working in After Effects
with okay so we're I we got I want to
touch on two things before we go we got
about five minutes left here so first I
want to talk about how you're
compositing this what you're doing to
composite it like if you have a before
and after of composited versus not
composited and then then the second
thing I want to talk about is the like
this light
spiral looks like a spell that's being
cast behind the character
um how you created that so I'll get into
those two things before we wrap it out
yeah
Okay so
to make this originally I just made it
in Photoshop just to the image then I
imported it to After Effects separated
it into a bunch of different elements
and animated everything in there here
I can show you
uh so it's the same way that did an
After Effects first
here's the project
I added a noise to just to give more
details in here so sick and I did the
whole animation in here
oh
so was this ever in 3D in blender or was
this always an after effects
uh then I rendered it into three
different parts the big circle the
smaller circles and the Runes of the
circles and put them into actual 3D
space and blender and Attract it to the
characters
I'm back
so
that extra little bit of like Parallax
looks so nice man ah so good yeah
also I just got a shout out before just
just very quickly
in the chat oh my God
someone I've known since like first
grade is in the chat right now that's
insane I hadn't talked to Sam in
freaking ages shout outs to you Sam God
that's very random for literally
everyone except Sam but I gotta say
what's up dude all right Dimitri
apologies you must continue
okay so an interesting thing that I did
for the first time was edit this pass
for tracking I didn't know how to
compose it to the elements easily so I
did this past I just put a bunch of 2D
planes into the actual 3D scene and then
use those squares to drag to the
elements in
uh so this was on the back of the
character and this was a little harder
to track I used a cropped the image only
to the middle part
uh to see on only this square and
tracked it with 3D camera tracker uh to
put extra to the elements to his back
awesome for example uh like this fire
element behind the
behind everything
um
so good and also I tracked some of the
sparks in there
uh I made some of the Sparks myself just
simulated them in right inside blender
[Music]
and some of those products was where the
pre-made elements from internet
um here I can show you the main thing
that
helps to composite the whole
image
uh really easily was
plugging cold
uh I just was it where's a super comp so
yeah yeah
um
I don't know where it's gone but I just
use the super com to compose everything
it's really useful because when you use
supercomp for compositing you can put
something some glowing element in the
background and it will add light wrap on
all of the top layers so you'll see like
um
like right here you can see the
background uh like
makes this glow on top of everything so
it looks really realistic it would look
the same way if you would shoot it with
an actual camera
oh man that's huge are you talking red
giant right a giant super calm
yep
that's a good one
absolutely so we've got about one we got
about one more minute for you Dimitri
here's the smokes I added to the scene
they're all tracked to three different
uh
parts of the scene so they would move in
the correct way
you'll see an actual movement of the
camera
even
between the smokes
this is such a huge this is such a huge
part of the render process is
compositing in you know it could be
Fusion or after effects but that
atmosphere layer you're doing right here
all this comp work is going on is
crucial to a render like it's not done
once it for me for me at least and it
seems like for you as well it's not done
once you get it in After Effects or
fusion and you really start working on
it is there is there a before and after
that you can show like your raw
um just like Beauty image and then your
final
only like this right here okay
so here's the roll 3D render and
here's the final
dang
so it changed quite a bit and the last
thing I want to say is I couldn't quite
figure out the
color grade for this image because it
was really it was changing heavily
between the first frame and the magic
part so what I did was I did two color
Grays first I put the recipients to the
first frame did a color grade that would
work for this Frame then I switched to
the part of the sequence where he casts
magic and did another grade and then I
just Blended between them with opacity
so it would start with one grid that
works for the beginning and gradually
uh transition to another one
and that took a long a lot of time to
figure out and last I think I did for
color grade was I did this legible pass
on top of everything
bleach with us was just
um grayscale copy of the image of your
life is overlay mode on top
and this is where I got this old movie
aesthetic
really contrasting
oh wow okay so you black and you did a
black and white thing and then like
overlaid it multiply or something or
something yep
um here's how it looked like before the
overlay
uh so just adds a lot of contrast to the
image oh okay and then for the for the
explosion I just stuck a bunch of uh 2D
um like uh effects on top of explosion
that I rendered from Eevee
originally I used it just for
as a placeholder because I didn't want
to make any more complex explosions I
didn't have enough time for that but
then I just had to leave it in there
just or expose it so it won't look too
janky that's what's up dude heck yeah
you work with what you got
that's amazing
um Dimitri I uh we gotta let you go here
we're gonna we'll have to move on but I
want to say thank you thank you so much
for for doing this putting everything
you had into this Challenge and come in
here and showing everyone your workflow
your style your art is amazing if you
guys want to see more of Dimitri's stuff
we got uh Linked In the description down
below go check them out
um but thank you again Dimitri and
congratulations to you man thank you
thank you so much for all that knowledge
thank you for for your challenges I
always learn a lot of uh stuff during
the process of liking my art for the
challenges heck yeah thank you hope to
see you on the next one
all right y'all
oh my goodness who
who is this Chris hello am I live are we
live we're live dude can you hear me
yeah oh my God
hi all right
how are you my friend how are you doing
I would say about equal parts excited
and nervous oh man no need to be nervous
we're just chilling having a good time
where are you from Chris uh I am from
Germany
um I live in a town called aachen which
is near cologne which might be something
that more people know so it's like when
you look at the map it's right where
Germany Belgium and the Netherlands meet
that's where I am right now and were you
born there
uh no I'm I moved here for University
okay nice so how long have you been
working with 3D
um I'm celebrating my two-year
anniversary this month dude what is this
is everyone a two years man oh my god
did you also get into 3D during covid
uh yeah
so I um I'm actually working in 2D
animation and I have been doing so for a
couple of years
um and I always wanted to learn 3D but
when you know how it is you want to do
stuff and then you just don't really get
around to doing it
um yeah yeah
but you know then then covet happened
and
um you know locked down and I was stuck
at home and that was really boring
um and I or I suddenly had all of this
free time on my hands so I decided to
finally do it and I started learning
Cinema
and um like originally I thought it
would was going to be like more to
complement my 2D workflow
um like I only wanted to be able to like
you know move around the camera around
like an object or like simple stuff yeah
um but but then it kind of like I
noticed it was like so much fun to do
and it kind of became this Obsession and
I wanted to learn like more and more
tools and more programs and you know
that's that's where I still am at so
what what was like what was the
obsession for you what was the most fun
thing for you about 3D
oh that's it's kind of everything I
think like I enjoy doing characters but
I also like doing
um like environment art
um
I love texturing
like
there's a few things I don't like like I
don't like great painting or retopology
but no stuff like that has to be done oh
that stuff's brutal I mean but dude it
really shows here like you're hitting
all of it you got your textures you got
your character you got your environment
and like did you do any of the other
challenges before this or is this your
first challenge
uh no that was my first one see man
I love it it's like those The Masks
totally remind me of like Crash
Bandicoot masks yeah
um and like what what what's your
reference for these characters like
yeah so I can show you a bit
um
like so I had like two main references
um for like the corrections actually the
scene as a whole
um so it take a lot of inspiration from
video games like I think a lot of people
yes
um and like one of my major influences
was the game Cana came out last year and
it follows this character
um it's set in this mythical forest and
she's being followed around by these
um cute little spirits and creature
thingies
um like these adorable little guys here
yeah
um and also
well I can't switch
the other major inspiration were like
the um
yeah yeah and the Zelda series
um which are also these like kind of um
Spirits like like Forest Spirit
creatures
popping up right now yeah
exactly that's great all right man yeah
I definitely get that vibe from your
render
um it's very cartoony it's very vibrant
um it's whimsical and fun
so you nailed it in terms of like
capturing your can you go back to your
prf board
real quick yeah sure
um like that's just screenshots of that
yeah it's fine
um is that a language on the right what
is what is that
oh yeah that's actually
um so I have in the background like you
can't even see it in the final rendering
um let me see if I can bring it up
somewhere
um
so like let me open this
so like in the very back there's like
these obelisks here and I etched a bit
of like writing on it and you can't see
it like at all yeah I totally can't see
it this is kind of like
this
there's actually some some text on it
and it says it translates to it
translates to iron Groot okay so it's
like it's just a very stupid uh kind of
like Easter egg and these um this this
alphabet uh comes from the game tunic oh
dude I'm playing that right now that's
crazy that's awesome
so um so yeah there's this the texture
that you find in the game that actually
translates to something
that's great yeah just like straight you
know they have like their own language
in that game in it like same thing you
know
a sign equals a another one equals B you
know yeah kind of like that
so that's just like a hidden Easter egg
that you don't even see anymore because
there's like leaves in front of it now
but well what's that let me ask you a
question like to take it one step back
from here
um how did you know what you wanted to
make like when challenge was announced
and you saw all the the mocap uh
animations did you know what you wanted
to do from day one or did this take you
a few days to like kind of figure out
um so I knew I wanted to do like this
little Spirit creature because I had
this like idea back in the back of my
head for a few months at that point
um but I never really really gotten
around to doing it yeah um and then I
heard about the theme of The Challenge
and I thought well this might actually
go pretty well together
um so I knew like adorable spittle
creature and obviously it's going to be
set in a forest somewhere and that was
about it when I started working with it
so
um I kind of immediately immediately
jumped into it and and started like
designing this this creature because I
knew the whole idea would like work or
break depending on whether I could get
it right
so I had like only like a rough idea of
how the the environment might look like
but I didn't even bother to actually
make a sketch or something I I just you
know try to get the character right
first and see if that works at all okay
all right so you're in Cinema 4D right
yeah all right so what's your process
for trying to get this character to look
right how did that go
okay so I actually start a zbrush for my
characters so it's gonna be like this is
kind of like representative of my
character workflow so I always start on
zbrush because it's just you know for me
it's way easier to to get like an
organic looking
um character like sculpted and zbrush
rather than trying to you know model it
in cinema
um so I will just start with a sculpt
and then which apologize it and then
I'll bring it into Cinema for rigging
and UV unwrapping
and then I'll take it into substance
painter well then like I have my my low
poly my rig low poly version of the
character and I'll take the high polygon
sculpt that I did previously and I'll
bake the
um all the details that I did on the
sculpt and that was lost during the like
scaling down to the to the low political
is this is this a normal map is this oh
yeah exactly it's normal baking yeah
like like you have essentially you have
two identical versions of the same model
like a very low polygon model that is
good for animation and it has good
topology to like Bend at the the right
places and then you have a very high
polygon object with a lot of detail that
it's like really unusable for for any
sort of animation and then you kind of
project all of that detail onto the low
poly version and then all those details
they exist in the texture maps and so
you get a lot of that detail back but
without actually adding anymore
geometry to it yeah so like I mean I I
know they do this in in video games a
lot because they need as much
performance as possible right so exactly
yeah I just started learning this
technique with uh with photo scans in
reality capture because you know those
photo scans man is like millions and
millions and millions hundreds of
millions of uh of of triangles
um and you gotta try and bake that down
into a usable you don't want to blow up
your program when you bring it in so all
right that's cool I'm that's cool that
you touched on that but yeah please keep
going very interested in this process
here
yeah and so then I have my uh my my
model in substance painter then I'll do
the text string there export my texture
Maps back into Cinema
um and then I'll build my shade on
redshift and then it's just applying and
rendering
and then I got I have my character
so this was step one for you
yeah that was like the first day
man you're so efficient that's great
yeah the thing is I I kind of started a
bit late into the challenge it was I was
already like the second week when I
heard about it
um
yeah yeah dang man I can't believe it
wow like you started 3D two years ago
and
you had half the time
with this art wow man crushing it all
right continue continue I'm so excited
about this yeah the problem was that uh
like I had this concept in my head but
you know
then I looked at the calendar I was like
oh [ __ ] I'm not gonna be able to do this
so I just put it away for two days and
did nothing then yeah um and and then I
then I kind of got angry at myself and
said okay now you gotta try and then I
kind of post this mini challenge to
myself so I said if you can do like this
one character
um like within a day from concept to fun
animation then I'm gonna try and go at
with the actual challenge
um so yeah that's that's why I did that
in one day
man that's awesome
that I think that's a great thing for
people to maybe try out like if
you know if you look at the full picture
you might get overwhelmed but
if you break it down into little parts
and and say you know if I can do this
little piece then I can keep going and I
know
like I I learned recently I have ADHD
and I'm just like my motor is constantly
running and I'm like
always working on stuff and I'll get
distracted sometimes and a lot of the
times
and but one of the things I learned with
ADHD was that it's difficult for us to
start a process like there's just
procrastination with starting something
that is the hardest part so if you can
start it you can just kick start it just
enough then you'll be there to finish it
out so
I think that's a really cool piece of
advice
yeah yeah exactly like break into two
small chunks so you know and kind of try
to to sketch like your timeline out and
and do one thing at a time so you don't
get lost in it like to like the correct
on the first day or like two days or I
don't know and then you do like
asset X then and asset assets y then and
you know look
try to like keep
like make a list so what's your next job
you work it off where do you go from
here uh so my next chunk was the actual
main character because like this was
just like secondary character yeah
um and I didn't quite know what my
actual main character was going to be at
that point because I was thinking okay
this might be like a humanoid or
something
um but you know making this little
Blobby thing takes like a day and making
an actual human character takes like a
lot longer than that and I didn't have
the time anymore
um so I was thinking
um how how I might be able to like cut
the corner there and I was thinking okay
maybe I can make it out of something
that I've already made but if
I've only really made this character so
I was thinking so maybe I can make the
character out of the character I just
made how would that look and like my
first impulse was that I would like
really look really weird
um but then I started making like
sketches and I was like jumping to this
like my head jump to his visual visual
joke of like the children standing on
top of each other and they're trying to
like act like a grown-up and they're
trying to get into a bar or something
and they're wearing a trench coat to
yeah like you know disguise themselves
and I thought okay this this might
actually be funny I could I should try
that
um so yeah these these are like a few
very rough sketches of that like I knew
I wanted to have like um the Torso
consisting of them and then like another
one for the Hat who's like controlling
um like the rest with the arms because I
also had this problem like the the the
spirits they they didn't have legs and
they only had like these very stubby
arms
um and but I but I still had to like fit
them into this human like shape so I had
to compensate for that somehow and
that's kind of how the puppet evolved
around that
yeah it was kind of like so good out of
this out of necessity really
so this is like a bit of um like work in
progress stuff here
man
um that's so good I love it man there's
like the two helpers on the bottom too
that's great exactly that's that's kind
of to suggest that um you know they they
might have built that themselves but
they're maybe not the best Craftsmen so
this might collapse at any second so
maybe like use two more to kind of
stabilize it so it doesn't fall over
Dude I love that you're like you took
the one step to making the first
character and then you're like okay I
did it now I have to like make a whole
other big character but I don't have
time so how the heck am I gonna do that
well I'll make it from Tiny I'll make it
from like a mix of the character I just
made and dude it's such a cool unique
character that you put together like how
how about these masks like where did The
Masks come into play
um so I knew I wanted to have uh like an
audience of those
um
but I didn't want
um you know I I only wanted to make one
character right yeah um so I but I
wanted them to look like different from
each other so I had to introduce variety
somehow there
and so I thought this this masks might
be like the best way to introduce
variety pretty quickly without too much
like effort here so obviously they have
different colors um like different body
colors
um but like The Masks here's like
another render
so dude yes
yeah so I made like a couple of
different mask shapes that's like just
four different shapes in total
um and then I just combined with
different accessories like different
horns and different leaves and feathers
and these are these these are just like
like small
variations of the basically the same
thing but then like recombine
differently each time and then you've
got like kind of a huge variety of that
yeah um
and then as combined with different
textures on top
um to to give it a more even more
variety
so maybe something interesting there
like for the textures and what I did was
so this is my redshift Shader graph for
the actual textures so what I did here
was to funnel them through a Shader
switch node and then I link that to an
object ID tag and what that enabled me
to do was
[Music]
um
select because later I would have this
huge crowd and it would be like really
annoying if I was like okay I want this
guy right there on the right I don't
want it to be read I want him to be
green because I don't like the red there
so to make like it's easier to Art
direct that
um I linked it to the ID tag so what I
could do now was just to switch through
to change this number here which each
character had
and then the
uh it's happening soon
and then the texture would
change
awesome all right so you build out a
system like a random seed thing but it
still gives you control so if you do
want this specific one to be
a certain look you could just set it to
that
yeah dang exactly right dude that's
awesome did you know how to build that
system before the challenge did you have
to learn that for the challenge
uh I did something similar before where
it's just completely random bass and I
tried to make it random bass but somehow
it wouldn't work and so this was just a
happy accident where it did like more
what I wanted it to do
um but it was actually the only thing
that actually worked in that I don't
know
was kind of a bug
so but yeah I kind of knew it so at this
point right you have your main character
you have your audience with their
different masks what's the next point
so the next Point uh was to actually
think about
um how the environment would look like
yeah
um so
I did like I started with a rough block
out uh in cinema that's just like just a
bunch of Cubes I knew I wanted to have
this kind of like Auditorium and like
the stage area here
um
but I really did nothing more here at
that point and then I just rendered that
out and threw it into Photoshop and did
a brilliant sketch on top
it's beautiful right yeah yeah exactly
that's all you need to look like I don't
know like 10 minutes or so
um it's actually it's more like like a
mental note for for myself
um so I know what it means nobody else
has to really be able to understand it
because I will be the only one who's
working on it
um
so yeah that's that's kind of like my my
reference from what I worked
um
off then
um and then I just you know started
making a list of all the assets I had to
I had to create
and I worked that off in the following
days
so your trees did you make those
yourself or were those assets
I made all the assets myself except for
like a few Leaf textures that I took
from substance Source yeah
um can you show your final render or
Soto can you switch over to me real
quick
yeah so
dude the more I look at the scene I'm
just blown away
um
everything is designed perfectly to fit
within this world
um Everything feels like it belongs it's
all kind of soft there's no hard sharp
edges
um like I would kill to play this game
dude uh I love okay so one thing I one
thing I really dig if you look on the
left up in the trees you have those
banners that are floating in the wind
like this
um you also have what looks like to be
like dried like mushrooms drying in the
tree or something like that up top and
like
um
you have this beautiful like wind thing
coming too like it's very subtle but
it's these little streaks of wind that
come across of course we have some
butterflies y'all you have some wind
particles and you have some leaves in
the air can you talk a little bit about
like the wind and how you captured that
look
okay yeah so
um I can maybe show some things yeah so
the um do you see my screen again yeah
yeah we got you
okay so
um let me jump into After Effects here
uh where is it so um
let me just scroll through here maybe uh
you have volumetric light too that's
like subtly animated
uh yeah all right man go for it what you
got I'm excited
um so yeah I wanted like like I wanted
to have all this tiny movement
everywhere um so I I threw some this
displacement on all of the leaves on the
scene like all the ferns are like slowly
swaying in the Wind
we just play this here wait you did that
in After Effects
uh no no no that's that's like all of
that is done Cinema okay
um
but yeah so the particles here there are
actually X particles um that are
rendered out separately and then
composite it on top you know after
effects wow okay
um the um all of these little banners
here and the flags they were simulated
and Marvelous Designer
and like the long
um like banners here on the right side
yeah yeah on the right and on the left
and the piece here and those actually
just um splines
um in cinema and then like
I wrapped some geometry around those and
like I think it's just a bit of
turbulence from Dynamics
yeah exactly
amazing are you in uh r26 s26
uh r26 yeah yeah they got that new rope
dynamics that are like super cool I was
using them for my thing as well but
that's that's pretty great and then the
flag on the right is that just cloth Sim
uh the the flex they're all Marvelous
Designer okay okay gotcha
dude
yeah and the actual uh like the these
these tiny wind uh uh effects yeah how'd
you get that
oh that is just uh edit on top in After
Effects that's
oh man this is a mess here where is it
uh winds here so
um that's just basically
like
um this one stroke effect that's drawn
on
and that is
like multiplied a couple of times
and
then I put some blur on it
dude and then that's combed on top like
there's really not much more to it that
that's like the perfect way to show wind
uh that oh man I'm not just I'm have to
like look into doing that on the some of
my future renders because that's a nice
very nice effect it feels it feels like
you want it to look like in like Ghibli
movies or like the breath of the wild or
something
the other was kind of the intent yeah
amazing amazing
shoot
um and then the leaves and everything
that's X particles
um these these small leaves floating
here there yeah that's X particles
awesome and there's actually some
there's actually some particular on top
like very very like
um tiny dust part I can see but you
actually can't really see them in the
final render anymore
like there's too much grain on top they
got lost how did you do the individual
like Leaf wind up top is that also just
displacement noise
um
let me think yeah I think I think it was
uh let me see if it's in here
look that's my tree speed tree
uh no that's a tail incidium tail
note like the guys who make X particles
they release this new Tool uh in in
Spring which lets you like create
awesome foliage
pretty quickly sick
yeah that's awesome and um I did the
trees with that and then I exported them
to zbrush and like rework them
um
but I took the leaves I used the leaf
steak yeah you can't see the necklace
that makes so much sense um yeah that's
awesome
yeah so I can't find it right here but
oh no here it is yeah it's just a
displacer and and there's like a noise
texture and this
um it's an animated noise in a displacer
deformer on the leaves
so
like perfect
does it play in the viewport it does
that's great
all right so you know we're we probably
have a couple more minutes here
um
is there anything that
you want to say or any advice you want
to give to artists
um who are just getting started or
maybe who uh who feels stuck
like what what do you do
when you feel stuck do you
yeah I mean I'll just say that
um when I feel stuck
um
tough one
um
I think like like
keep in mind that that everybody is
feeling like that at some point like um
it's not the end of the world if stuff
doesn't work out as you you know you
wanted to immediately but you know keep
at it
um I I often have this moment like when
I'm working on a scene
like there's always a time where
everything looks like crap
um where you look at it and you think
this doesn't work
but it often is like that it doesn't
work yet and you kind of there's like
often this moment where you just have to
push through
um and stuff and and eventually you will
get to a point where
um where it improves
um and and and you will get to a point
where you are more satisfied with the
stuff you're working on
[Music]
um
and also if you like if you're
interested in
getting getting into this like
do it and then don't don't be like me
and say for years like okay I'm gonna do
it eventually
um just you know just just try to make
the time and actually jump into it
um and also like try to connect to other
people and other artists online
because that's something that I haven't
done as well for like a long time I've
just been doing stuff for myself and
like keeping involved to myself I'm not
sharing anything but the moment you like
get yourself like get your stuff out
there and and share with other people
and you know get get feedback
um you you will grow and the community
is like really awesome and it's very
encouraging so
yeah man okay yeah yeah absolutely
absolutely I think finding that
community and finding that support is
crucial
um you know it's kind of
one of the
the after effects of
you know
me starting the Discord because you like
the Discord was for the weekly
challenges
just to you know so other people could
join on these challenges that I was
doing on the Stream
um but it turned into this massive
community of people who are like wanting
to help each other out and I think
without the community it's definitely
harder way harder to create
um but you know to also touch on what
you're saying too like
I think it's really important if you
want to do something to just go for it
and I know that it might be hard to dive
into something that you don't know how
to get started in so the hardest part is
always starting for me personally you
know I think like
it's when you're going to be your worst
but it's so important to start to start
because
you know you're never going to freaking
win
the challenge like you just did if you
didn't start right so
and and also to touch on what you're
saying about your art looking bad for a
long time like yes that will happen you
will get it will be a thing even even
like when you got it figured out and you
feel confident and
you know your art there's going to be
times where it just doesn't look good
and I I can say just from experience
that that's the case every time I create
something it it never looks good for
like a while
and then not until like the last
moments does it really start coming
together and you just have to trust that
that time will come and the more
experience you have
the faster that time will come
but yeah there's always a period where
you're just like kind of down
on yourself and like
because your art doesn't look good but
yeah I don't think there's any reason to
be down on yourself I think you just
gotta the more you do it just trust in
the process and
you know you'll get there but um
yeah Christian any any final words oh
real quick Sorry by the way if you guys
want to follow uh Chris his link is down
below in the description
um we're linking to what'd you send your
YouTube your Instagram our station I
forget
I think in the description that's my
YouTube it's um I think I only got like
12 subscribers and two videos on it but
there's like links to my art stage and
Instagram as well whereas like I got a
lot more stuff on there from your
YouTube they can find that from the
YouTube
yeah okay sweet yes go check him out
guys uh fantastic artist Chris I can't
wait to see what you do on the next one
and thank you so so much for for joining
us thank you for putting in all this
effort in August and crushing this
Challenge and for joining us and giving
us all that great info man I'm I'm
definitely gonna look back on this this
stream and lots of little nuggets of
infoman so thank you thank you thank you
yeah thanks for having me
absolutely all right man we'll catch you
soon all right
all right bye-bye there man peace
first
is this this
Mr Andros
what's the X
yeah
can you hear me now oh can't hear you
yeah the ax is uh
okay
I'm here
I
okay okay y'all getting this figured out
behind the scenes so much he's on the
case
all good guys do you hear me
I can't hear you but I can hear myself
hold on
okay
I think this works can you hear me
Andres
yes I can hear you
all right guys I think this will work
it's a little like you know a little
workaround but we're we're getting there
um Soto can you check your screen share
on Discord let's see I want to make sure
I can see what's going on here
there we go
I don't know there we go yep
I can see that
thank you chat thanks for bearing with
us
yeah I see a white screen Soto
there it is
we're good
back to the white screen
it's good now
all right
Andres are you alive
yes I'm here I can hear you it's all so
sweet yeah we're good
okay
okay so
um you were asking about my name I think
uh
can you hear me
because I can't yeah anything okay yeah
yeah
it is a little laggy
yeah okay so my name my real name is
chonto which is a
Hungarian the CH is
CS which is an ex in English so it's
hard to pronounce in English so I just
use an X to
everybody to be able to pronounce my
name so it sounds super cool X yeah
um so for those of you who don't know
Andres won first place in the moving
meditations 3D Challenge and
dude your art is freaking so cool man I
love everything about this the way that
you're using the mocap data to
alter you know and to manipulate these
scientists and this room that you built
out you have a lighting shift that goes
down the thing looks photo real you're
doing a lot of cool Dynamics here
um like uh some destruction on the right
with the tile and everything the
flickering lights up top are incredible
your claw simulations you're firing on
all cylinders here so I want to break
this down with you
starting with first off
where are you from
I'm from Hungary which is kind of like
Eastern Central Europe from Budapest
that's the capital
yeah and I'm from here yeah
where did you how did you get started in
3D what was the first thing that you
were like oh I gotta do this
3D uh
first I was shown this at school I was
in high school I was attending an art
high school and I learned animation
there and there were they were teaching
us 3ds Max but I didn't like that
software that much and
I never really touched 3D since until
2017.
yeah
okay she's been about for five years
five plus years yes yes but I was
working in
[Music]
animation into the animation
and
yeah
nice okay so
you know when you hear you're in blender
is that correct
yes yes blender yeah
awesome man awesome very very cool
um so when you heard about this
challenge in August
like where was your mind at were you
thinking about this idea specifically or
was it something completely different
how did you get to the point where
you're like this is the idea I want to
aim for
yeah it was um kind of by chance I can
say that there was this uh
fan design magazine or something which
we were making with my friends about
UFOs and aliens and I was doing
characters for that and then the
challenge came and I had this UFO
character this alien character
and then just
uh
the first thing in my mind was I want to
use that character and then things
started flowing in from different
directions so my girlfriend was watching
stranger things at the time and that was
obviously an inspiration and yeah
kind of like that I mean yeah totally I
see it so that's it's cool man like you
started with a character in mind and
the stranger things too I just finished
season four which is
so good
yeah yeah
and uh um actually sorry
one moment sorry we're doing this back
this like work around for the audio so
can you turn down the music a touch
or just turn it off for like monitoring
[Music]
thanks dude perfect
um so yeah I mean I get I get the
stranger things vibe from this
definitely so it seems like you had a
perfect mix of
ideas come together
um starting with the character and
yeah it's a great way to have some solid
Direction yeah
at first I just thought this is an alien
guy he could do magic levitate things
and just what if he just uh levitates
some trash or something in an Alleyway
but soon I dropped that idea and it came
to my mind this Wagner things when he
just ruins people and
from that from
then it just flowed in this direction
yeah that's such a beautiful process
when like you can get that ideas coming
together and have a direction and know
exactly what you're gonna do and you
just knock it out from day one
um
amazing you're blessed with a great idea
early on it seems
Yes Yes actually I started sorry
oh no go ahead yeah yeah actually I
started the whole process
um two weeks in August so cool and the
last yeah I started it I think the third
week or the second week yeah oh my God
man if you didn't have that like perfect
combination of idea and character then
this wouldn't have happened
yes yes I think so yeah how stressed out
were you like when you were making this
art it's really tough to create it's
like hey make the best thing you've ever
made and do it in this short amount of
time and it better be good like were you
stressed out during this process
actually I was doing some other work and
I fractured my wrist so I had to work
like this I couldn't use my left thumb
which is crucial for keyword comments so
it was a bit tough yeah I can say that
dude you were
it's like the world tried to hold you
back but you were like no I'm gonna get
first kiss
I was uh
I couldn't believe it at first you know
wow all right so let's get into this art
man tell me about this process how do
you begin uh putting this scene together
yeah
um I'm gonna show you I don't know the
blend file Maybe
so at first I I had this
let's go with pictures
sorry a minute
but you're good
we got time so I accepted this alien
character this day is so sexy yeah yeah
he was made in an iPad and this app
called Nomad Scout
yeah uh I generally scored in an iPad
and what's the problem
it's it's called Nomad sculpt
Nomad amazing okay
yeah it can handle around
20 million vertices I think so it's
pretty decent it's capable of
pretty high quality scarves
so yes oh it's definer
character and then I um wait hold on
let's see that again go back to that
character let me see that video real
quick that's nice
yeah I mean it's just isolated the
character
[Music]
is this Marvelous Designer with the
cloth yeah yeah it was made in the
program oh so good I love you can see
through it
and also it's something also the tubing
in his arm is also made in marvelous
just with a glass material
[Music]
it's okay okay so you started with the
character you start with the cloth you
kind of locked your character in you
picked the animation that you knew would
kind of alter the environment with that
like slam right yes yes for the and
picking the animation was um
I almost instantly knew I want to number
18 because that was this impact in it
and I very much like that so it was an
easy choice
so yes and uh what's next environment or
the scientists
no actually I was retargeting the
animation and tweaking the
[Music]
tweaking the animation because there was
a lot of clipping because he has a long
limbs long arms long legs so there is so
much clipping I was cleaning that up and
then
I think that after that I was doing some
Basics basic uh environment something
like this level or a little bit less
just just this basic Corridor and
and the textures
what are you using for reference on this
are you just off the top of your head or
what
uh I I was looking at references
uh actually I use stable diffusion for
that
it's gonna store my work uh my living
it's so good
but with the alien character it wasn't
that good so
like this this I described in Alien yeah
and I was also looking at real pictures
for recorders and yeah a funny story
because I fractured my my arm my wrist I
was in the hospital many times so I am
what no way through through inspiration
from there as well so actually you can
see these uh
lines in my animation you can see these
lines on the floor there's some crappy
lines in the hospital which shows you uh
the X-ray room is there or the
different rooms is where at so I
Incorporated that photograph in this oh
my God that's dude that is so crazy like
if you didn't break your wrist your art
would be as good
yeah
what the heck you're you're just
absorbing everything around you like in
these two weeks to put out the perfect
piece of art I love it wow
yes
and uh
yeah so what's next yeah
um yeah next I was doing the
uh
okay
[Music]
the the scientist characters yeah yeah
they have a they have a nice and
unfortunately I lost that file when when
I could show you but I was making make
the doing the rigs in miximo okay and
also
and I downloaded maximum animations and
I combine them with this
thing called non-linear animation in
blender but you can combine different
fbx
skeletal animations into one and also
when the impact happens when
they slam to the wall that part and this
uh broken every bone
these were custom animations which was
made by me and I combined these
different animations in the nla animator
and a combiner blender
and
then you have to bake that animation to
one and exported it then to Marvelous
Designer yeah so that yes and whatnot
yeah but that was a real pain the
orientation of the animation in blender
is looked good but marvelous and I don't
know why it kept
changing orientation so it was a pain
and
and after many many hours of trial and
error I found out that there is a
maximum plugin which can generate
contrary for your mixer animations and
if I generate the contrary in blender
then I could export it to marvelous and
then magically it works I don't know how
but yeah that was my workflow I think
two days was
spent with this thing so I was a bit
nervous
well I mean it's smart that you decided
to go with the character workflow next
because those are the elements needed to
tell the story of your scene right and
like you easily could have gone into
doing the detail of the environment
which for me would be the most fun I I
really don't enjoy doing character stuff
um and dealing with all those technical
problems but you're really smart in that
like you tackled that first and foremost
because that is the element needed to
tell the story of your render
yes it's it's something uh it that comes
from my line of work
um usually most of the time I'm working
at theaters in in Theatrical place where
there is a
some animations in the background and
sometimes the director says let's change
it by tomorrow so you have to work fast
and I learned to prioritize and I really
like messing around with little bits of
the environment
that line of things but I knew that I
have not that much time so I have to get
through the characters which is the most
time consuming part of the task
do you enjoy doing the character stuff
sorry I didn't hear you there do you
enjoy it do you like doing the character
stuff or do you more enjoy the
environment and Lighting
Parts yes
I like both but I really much like
scouting different interesting
characters but with humans and dimension
not that much so yeah I see maybe yeah I
can say environment is is a more more
enjoyable for me
So speaking of the environment here
um
two questions
how much time do you have to create the
environment like how much time is left
for you and then what did you do to like
detail and max out this environment what
was your process
okay so I was doing the basics and about
a day or something decoded
then I just moved in
piece by piece some downloaded assets
and my own photographs
and and done this fog around the
scene this Haze
it
it was fun but it wasn't that much time
nice okay and so that like the haze and
stuff that's built in with blender but
then you also have like particles in
your final render
um that would that be after effects work
yes that was made in After Effects let
me show so we'll we'll get we'll get to
like the compositing in After Effects
probably a little bit more towards the
end what what else okay we'll stay in 3D
here what else are you doing like do you
have any uh like moments or tips and
tricks on like let's say the tile
breaking on the right side is that just
a very basic uh Dynamics it's kind of a
setup or you do anything special for
that yeah
uh yeah it's kind of a funny thing
because um
I made it
and you won't believe me but this is
keyframe animation because it's just
some very basic uh simulation it should
be but it didn't want to work that way
and uh just get a handy those tiles
yeah and just looked at it and said okay
it's just
five
for the keyframe for each diode not that
much so I just do it that way it's it's
again it was a less time so just instead
because it was less time yeah yeah I
have this Habit to do everything in the
least amount of time the best with the
best output so I'm just right well
that's a good habit to have man I like I
I need to do a little bit more of that I
feel like I spend a lot of time on the
details that aren't
necessary you know because I pride
myself on the details but at a certain
point I have to realize that when it's
necessary and when it's not and I think
your workflow of doing the quick like
going for the quickest way to get a
version out and then you'll make it
better if it needs to look better after
that I think is the only way you were
able to even make the the time limit
with this
yeah I'm also very much like to do
little stuff and lost in details but uh
but yeah I have this Habit to to get to
a decent point and if I have time I can
spend years but yeah yeah
yes
um okay so before we move on to the
after effects side of things and
bringing your render to its final form
are there any little things that you
want to mention or touch on when it
comes to like the blender side of things
and
yeah I I'm in this basic vertical system
animation simulation for the tires
and
I also
which is
I don't know
everything you can see everything I
think and also there was this
simulation with the papers which didn't
make it to the Final Cut but there was
this version when the papers these files
which they keep on the test subject are
flying nice but yeah the final version I
didn't use the
you know I think one thing that I love
so much about your art is that the mocap
data
affects the environment and I think
that's a big thing that a lot of people
didn't do was have their mocap data
affect the environment and I think it's
so important because you're going above
and beyond it's like
you should definitely like especially if
you're picking something with that that
has an impact
it should affect the environment or I
honestly should it's you know all
subjective but you're doing such a good
job of it
um and you know it feels like a
complete a whole complete world that you
put together so
you're gonna render this out right and
then you're gonna bring it into after
effects and you're gonna start
compositing this thing so do you have a
version like before and after
compositing or no
oh yeah I have
um just a minute
so this is the final and uh yeah it's
after this was the so blender
rendered this this was the render
straight from Cyprus there is the lights
the haze everything the volumetrics and
this was the final
composting it's it's not
yeah you can say there is a difference
of course
um can you do me a favor can you close
blender right now because you're coming
in a little choppy on the Discord side
okay I closed it
all right that's sweet so you're adding
this like dust particles which
I think is a very very very big thing to
add
um it does a lot and it's a very subtle
thing but you're killing it with those
particles and yeah you got some like
smoke in the background too is that
right
yes yeah yes I've tried to make the
impression if there is a fire in the
background in the in another area and
they're escaping from the fire and
the alien guy is also escaping from his
prison yeah and he caused the fire
of course
so um
like besides color correction and
whatnot are you adding any diffusion are
you adding film grain are you doing like
any other special lens kind of things in
After Effects
yes uh at the film grain and uh
different layers of uh adjustment layers
and this kind of glow thing which is
just uh uh
white layer masked out and in additional
mode blend mode
and also I made these uh warp effects
and this
oh you call it this
RGB shift effort
yeah okay
you can see it better
here
yeah yeah so
actually as soon as the scientists
feet leaves the ground there is some
displacement in the whole
whole picture
if you can see that yeah definitely yeah
I think it really makes it feel
otherworldly
yeah I that was my goal yeah and when
the impact happens there is this
I don't know this energy
board or something like that
it's so good man your lighting comes
together perfectly and like the way the
lighting shifts and all these little
subtle things you're doing come together
for such a huge
impact in the end it's amazing
yeah the lighting was
pretty much
but I'm pretty sure I think is
helping to sell this thing uh
I used it's so dark and Sinister too on
the red like when he when it's just
backlit on the red
yeah actually it's just
some faking and there is area lights
behind it which make this Rim light
also with with the here oh that's it
but there are also other red lights in
the background just some kind of uh
alarm alarm light
yes it's so good the the lighting man I
think that's like the the biggest thing
with yours is the lighting it's just
incredible
subtle too
thanks
that I made this flickering almost in
every light source which was just some
modifiers and blender
noise modifiers
with limits right so
everything flickers which I think helps
to add that other otherworldly energy
going on vibe
it's perfect I I you know before before
we close it out here I want to ask you
do you have anything that you would like
to say to the audience any words of
advice that you would like to say to
people who maybe didn't make it into the
top 100 what would you say to them
yes I I
saved them that and it's kind of obvious
but never give up and because
and
so many times there will be setbacks and
something like that but just keep going
never really
think about
the
that you have to perform something just
is
there is you
and you learn
from everything and if you learned from
something
that's that's the biggest price I think
and
agree yeah agreed I think people just
need to
ex like if it's about winning the prize
there's only so many there's only five
people who win and like yeah top 100
sure they got kid bash stuff but like at
the end of the day it comes down to like
did you have a good time creating did
you learn while you were creating like
did you make friends along the way you
know
yes yes
and especially uh before uh before these
challenges before your I was doing your
challenges I never really
[Music]
talked with other people from in the
industry or in the 3D scene and I
learned so much from the Discord from
doing vehicle challenges from doing this
and just pop my verb there and ask
people do you have any
uh thoughts on that and they help so so
you could learn from I think the the
most important thing is to learn
yeah yeah keep the fire going
you know everyone has a desire to get
into it because it's fun you gotta keep
that fun going and that that's you know
what we try to do with Discord with the
weekly challenges with these big
challenges here so
um man Andre said I really appreciate
you thank you so much for your time
congratulations again big congrats for
winning this whole challenge I hope to
see you on the next one can't wait to
see what you're gonna put out man but
again thank you please enjoy the rest of
your evening and uh
I really appreciate you man thank you so
much thanks for having me it was a
really really another thank you
absolutely man I'll catch you soon yeah
yeah
all right peace out man
hi
all right everybody
um so that is four out of five
um winners for this challenge now
there's one more artist that we need to
look at
um and that's gonna be jihoon who's from
Korea who goes by Anna on Discord and uh
jihoon put together the time lapse robot
so I want to get into a little bit of
that uh jihoon's English isn't
to the point where we can have a back
and forth
um on Discord live with you guys right
now so what jihoon did was he put
together
um a little video breakdown with some uh
subtitles for you guys to follow along
with and
um I'm I'm gonna play it right now for
you guys it's an amazing little
breakdown that he put together lots to
learn as always
um so let's take a little bit here and
check out jihoon's breakdown and when we
come back I'm gonna get into the weekly
challenge I'm gonna announce the five
winners for the weekly challenge
uh which was upgrade was the theme of
the week and I will announce the next
weekly challenge all right so
let's enjoy jihoon's breakdown for his
uh homeless robot time lapse
oh hello everyone my name is chiffon and
I am Anna in this quote
I would like to thank Quinter for
choosing my work
to get big surprise
thank you so much
I made a video about how I started 3D
and how I made my scene so please enjoy
the video
in 2004 I watched the video of a game
called your routine
it may be common in these days but 18
years ago came animation with such
energy and style was a layer in Korea
I was purely shocked and soon I became
interested in computer graphics
I was interested in 2D illustration with
some graphics and 30 CG but
unfortunately the earliest thing I lost
interest in was
3D graphics
because at the time the performance of
the home computer was not good enough to
3D modeling
foreign
in 2019 I happened to bind a video of
Ian schwart
model simple dude great job
it's a workflow and optimization tricks
gave me another shock and I think of 3D
again
I started studying the printer and
especially for the past year and a half
I was deeply observed in it
I am currently trying to figure out what
I can achieve with this
I recently became interested in the AI
generated image
I saw the picture of homeless robot in
the YouTube video of cliff alexandrov
maybe the idea itself was common but the
way it was expressed seemed really
unique
so I paid enough with these images
therefore when I started the challenging
basically what I wanted to make is
homeless robot doing something
and then I happened to remember about TV
program I watched as a kid
the show which introduced authenticism
in India
the general image about the citizen
would be coastered as fasting or citizen
meditation but it had extreme cases
on a fatigue lived with their left arm
above his head in his whole life
I mean other people might take two
directions as religious or meditative
purpose but who knows their real
intention
I imagine the eyes of others who did not
understand what other texts would feel
so I thought what if a lot thoughts on
incredibly slow moving meditation
only about inner self so what if no one
understands
I wanted to make a scene like that
logout is an important process but the
shin I designed the world very simple so
it ended very quickly
my background only consists of ground
buildings and billboard
one was more important in this scene was
timing
I moved the Box around Imagining the
main characters and supporting
characters to interact with and checked
what I had to make
all 10 remains is to solve each
components one by one
lender has a skytestinal you can express
the plot of time by addressing its sound
elevation parameter
however there was a problem that this
background only works in Cycles
I had to find a way to solve this
because I was planning to make a Divi
I thought that if Sky texture was output
as an HDR image it could be used in EP
so I animated the sky and printed it out
as an open EXL images sequence
when the immediate sequence was loaded
the sky texture is now locked on eBay
I said the output resolution very low
the religion is the first because the
sky texture is almost too empty so I
sold 200 pixels was enough
secondly I was worried about future
memory shortages
I want you to use building models as
light as possible just like the sky
first I took some pictures near the
South Station
these buildings look like they could be
created with the procedure texture
I made a base by using the brick texture
then simply modeled some details
till it looked blend so I used a random
block colors to make the normal
Direction slightly different for each
window
finally I made a simple interior and
built the inside of the building
this is how my media computings were
made
I animated the clock in printer and
printed it out as an English course
for the same reason as before it clocks
also have tiny resolution
even though the image is so small with
mass node it can have sharp boundaries
still it looks jaggy but let's call it
stylized
to make a big autovertisement I used a
free stock video
using a screen capture program I took
screen every one or two seconds then
moved to PowerPoint and add text
animation
I mix the clock and back it with mixed
RGB note
screen is completed
I part of the main character from my
abandoned project which I made a mother
but couldn't do it
I'm not good at human catering but I
could do with the robot
this is because robots do not need to
use a maturity Pawn
your thoughts have to appear to each
part directly to the Bone
I separated the joints of my character
and made them like a robot
protected using the AI generated image
it may look horrible and backside is not
even textured but I didn't care because
only the front side will be on the
screen
I used Jan Schubert patreon a set with a
crowd and geometry knows to control the
movement of the cloud at once
first connect the scene time node to the
set position node
frequently put top pressure node between
the two
for animation is now repeated every one
second
it is important today the Olympic range
is 0 to 1 because block carbon node can
be used
if you use the protocol to assign
different movement for each axis then
adding motion can be produced
finally by using random value node as
time offset
animation is complete without tapping to
pay attention to the timeline or grab a
little
these moving people are very awkward If
You observe them closely
but I chose to tablet up your attention
rather than spend time on extra detail
because if there are people who interact
with the main character the viewers will
focus on them
when I made these robots I used the
object in preload this node output or
random value whenever the object is
duplicated
therefore if you use it as a factor of a
color lamp node you can make the robot
have a different colors each time it is
duplicated
I will show you today for you by cutting
it
this image texture seems to last
gradually from top to bottom so I put
all the rubies in the upper quarter and
change it to pre-coordinate as the
object was duplicated
this method allow the robots to have a
variety of textures
this low board is just the project
mapping of AI generated image but the
head part was not good to use as it was
so I dig throughout my old Polaroid
camera in 3D second
these three people are based on my own
3D scale models
there were several problems with the
huge industritis can result as they were
first scanning or Schumann can easily
distort the base and hand
second unlike robot human character
leading is a difficult and long lasting
task
I couldn't find a solution for a few
days so I even thought about changing
the workflow from blender to onion
engine they could use a metal human
or finally the way I came up with watch
to use the MDA which is a pre-planatory
tone
provided a fully leaked character body
so if I remove the arm and face of the
3D scan and Transplant the body of the
mvlay then I could completely bypass the
leaking process
so I multiplied my 3D Scale Models to
fit the body of the MB lab
then parented them to the amateur
and this episode of MB lamp bodies but
x-ray data by data transfer modifier
now it becomes a fully leaked 3D circuit
models
to be honest I think to make a character
animation I just let the characters post
for each plane
my scene is the sixth second long
compression of 16 hours so one play
means seven to eight minutes
so I tried to match my animation to the
speed but then they moved so fast
if you take a picture of the city every
seven minutes then nothing will look
continuous
this may be physically accurate but it
is very disturbing and cannot create a
meaningful story
they are poor I decide to adjust every
movement or screen time not real time
what I did was not animating I just
posted photo characters in each frame
actually daughter Prince would read so
maybe people would not know more than
that the characters are just interacting
with a girl
the battle is I wanted them to make some
being reported at each frame
I intentionally removed the motion blur
of certain characters to attack the
viewers attention
Cyprus had the option to turn button
block on and up for each object
unfortunately EB does not have the
picture
however there is a cheat method to do
this Contour in EB
the motion blue option is said to start
from playing when the engine will report
to the space between the current plane
and the next frame to create a motion
blur
for instance in this screenshot render
will label between 5th and sixth plane
to render fifth plane
they are poor by controlling between the
prince
the intensity of the motion blur may be
adjusted
it is generally a typical difficult to
do because politics purpose keep playing
must be inserted into every single plane
in my case this was easily possible
because I made their project in every
plane so there was already a key plane
without any space
to completely remove the motion blur
over specificator I selected the
keyframes then pressed T to set it
constant
each little petals were made or the
inter project
the body was originally made but it was
typical to increment a motion in which
the wings were pulled and unpolated
I just made the wings separately and
animate them by limiting height and
unhide
these Prime papers are not accumulation
but a geometry node animation
is difficult to fully explain the
internal structure but the basic
principles are as follows
first use a common multiplier to depend
to stop divided plane
then rotated both the paper and the
curve separately
now it looks like applying paper
it could all be implemented inside the
geometry node so or I have left
tutorials animate the location of the
paper
I didn't do much support process like
color grading in this project because
all the adjustments were already made
for the Timeless impact
the last thing I added was a simple
feeling grain
although granny pack I missed download
texture with the rendered images and
finally connected to learn to detox node
I was able to PC all the work in blender
like this
and this is how I made a short but long
six second animation
I thank Clint was again I am very
oppressity
I think type of social media about
blender or 3D CG because I watched a
math teacher until last year but
I'm going to start to print a YouTube
channel from now on
although it's Korean but if you don't
mind then please see tutorial URL below
thank you for watching
oh man
so much good info the dude is a wizard
when it comes to blender it's like
everything is so smart and it's just
enough
to to cheat his way through to the final
piece of art and I saw a visual set in
the comments too like y'all were digging
that
um visual is saying like if it's the
perfect example of favoring the art
versus what's real
um and it's just freaking perfect wow
um jihoon if you're watching this thank
you so much for putting that together
that was a really really nice breakdown
um it'll be here for you guys definitely
go check out uh his YouTube channel that
he just started it's all in Korean I
don't know if there's English subtitles
but you know definitely check them out
see if you can follow his stuff it's
linked below as well as all the other
artists who are on today with us
um
yeah super super nice I hope you guys
got a lot out of this stream I know you
got a lot out of just that last
breakdown from jihoon Alone
um
brilliant absolutely brilliant thank you
guys for for joining me thank you for
learning with me for growing with me
um it's a forever and ever all right we
are we are always on the case always
trying to learn and grow and have fun
together so that's it that's that's the
five the top five for you guys um I hope
you enjoyed it what we're gonna get into
now
um before we wrap it out is the weekly
challenge we got uh
let's see it was upgrade was the prompt
for last week we're gonna get into that
and uh see what you guys submitted I'll
show you the top five winners and then a
little bit of honorable mentions as well
and uh then from that point tell you
guys what this week's weekly challenge
is and we'll get into maybe just a
little bit of q a I'll hang out with you
guys before we call it quits so uh
without further Ado let's hop into the
uh weekly challenge review
all right
so let's get into it like I said it's
upgrade right if you guys want to do
these weekly challenges they're great
ways to uh practice your art every
single week for you know whenever you're
feeling like having fun and doing a
little weekly challenge it gets you
ready for the big 3D Community
challenges a lot of these people who did
these and who even won these who made
top 100 they've been working on their
weekly challenges on the Discord for for
some time now so
um let's start it off with metatrox
you're our first winner
um for upgrade I love the story behind
this
um it you know beautifully rendered
really really nicely done great
characters great lighting very simple
um but like I said it's the story about
this one
upgrade was the prompt right so on the
left what you have is a character with
an old like medium format film camera
and on the right you have the same
character grown up years later and the
way you put it is we downgrade while
technology upgrades and you can see you
know they got the cine lens on the DSLR
upgraded
Hardware there I think is so cool and
you portrayed this in a really cool way
you didn't have to worry about the
background it's not about the background
it's about your characters and what
they're holding so you nailed it kept it
simple
so congrats to you metatrox you get 15
points to your uh to your role on the
Discord server and you guys literally
rank up you there's a visual like emblem
and badge that comes with these weekly
challenges that you get points for by
only doing these weekly challenges
um
so congrats to you y'all I hope you're
leveling up
next up
we have Naz Nas
um
whoa here we go yeah there we go that's
an ass uh dude freaking
super sick all right so this one you got
story you also have composition you got
color you got a pretty photo real setup
going here really nice Bend in the
T-shirt there you got a nice cloth Sim
going
um
who knows if that's a brush or how you
did it but it looks great
this one's hilarious all right so
basically the story here is you got a
kidney
that was removed from this character for
a graphics card and I understand you
know give an arm and a leg for these
things but in this case you give a
kidney
um I love your composition I love that
low angle shot your color is awesome
it's the blue and red kind of color
combo which is super fun you got a
little bit of fog in here too it's
really
give the scene a bit of atmosphere
um and you packed it full of details it
feels very realistic
um it looks like you got that Matrix
Unreal Engine I think you did this in
Unreal Engine is what you said you got
that Matrix scene I noticed those ground
wires that keyboard that monitor
definitely some of those Matrix assets
um but yeah this is looking awesome
really nice scene you put together it
lit very well
so congratulations to yanaz 15 points to
you for crushing it next up
we got obliv
yes
looking like some Destiny dude you put
this together as a combination of uh
hand modeled custom modeling and kid
bashing to put this together
it's wonderfully lit
like movie quality your background is
freaking awesome I'm not sure if that's
rendered or a photo but man it fits
perfectly uh the like warm light
bouncing off of this main character's
chess piece is incredible your detail is
off the charts it's a very simple little
uh environmental portrait of this
character here
maybe the skull needs to be a touch
bigger it looks a little small but that
makes it even creepier
dang
good stuff very very good stuff 15
points to you for an incredible render
um beautiful color too
gotta love it
next up we have our very own visual
congrats visual I know you in the chat
congratulations man this is top-notch
work this is two weeks in a row for you
I think
um
a lot of people went with that sci-fi
prompt
um I think metatrox with that camera I
think he was like the only winner I
believe who did uh something non-sci-fi
but visual I think
I think you're crushing it here with
this the Sci-Fi angle on this prompt
um your detail is incredible your
character work is incredible uh this is
Daz you're using and you're doing custom
uh Textures in Octane and c4d your
materials are ridiculous your character
design is ridiculous I love the way you
think about your characters man so good
so so good great color too very simple
good lighting just all around knocking
it out the park man congratulations to
you 15 points
keep it going keep going and finally the
last winner of the weekly challenge the
upgrade weekly challenge is
Ernest goal
yes yes you hand modeled all this
so good
so so good
your composition and your lighting are
freaking perfect man I love it
so cool like I feel like I can actually
touch this character the design is
amazing
your textures are awesome I love the way
you're doing like uh
you have like a little Edge and octane
would be a dirt node
and it will allow you to control the
texture on the edges of things if you
look on the brow area you can see that
all those little lines they have like a
white kind of outline to them and it
makes it feel worn and used and your
texture work is great here
really beautiful lighting you're really
bringing out the face with that orange
everything else kind of falls off the
cyan and then we have that pink that hot
pink on the background here
and all those wires too looking great
congratulations to you and to the rest
of the top five for the upgrade weekly
challenge
but you know that ain't it because we
got some honorable mentions to get into
um sotomontay I will mention some of
these are video
um one so just make sure the audio
doesn't explode so just keep an eye on
it
um but first off we got wondrous
honorable mention to your wondrous this
is great
um
this is a recreation
of uh a album cover by a rapper whose
name I forget I saw it when I looked it
up yesterday uh when picking these
winners
but dude you even put together a like
AI generated like rap song that came
with this it's so good so good you
really knocked out this like
remix of this album cover
um
beautiful
beautiful work great lighting
great color
really solid all around
next up we have I Hagen E Hagen
yeah this one's really nice this one's
super nice this was you said it was kit
bashed uh from a bunch of different
assets that you put together
um you know total classic
upgrade uh sci-fi kind of little scene
here I love the city in the background
light very Blade Runner of course we all
we all want to experience a city like
this if you're ever in Tokyo in Shinjuku
place called Shinjuku
kind of feels like this just a little
bit Shanghai as well Shanghai feels a
little bit like this too but
I think you're digging the uh or I'm
digging the composition you got going
here I love how she has Shades too it's
like
just dark as night up in here
maybe you could um push the foreground
lighting a little bit brighter feels a
little dim
um curious to you know where that light
is coming from like an overhead lamp or
something but
yeah just a little something small uh
next up honorable mention each one of
you guys are getting Five Points here to
your role on the server we got Mandy e
H same situation I love the colors
though but you modeled this hand by
yourself which I thought was very very
impressive
um it's a really cool look you got that
muscle kind of blending in to the metal
um
I thought you did a really good job I
love this cartoon look that you have
going on and these soft colors you're
killing it with these soft colors so I
wanted to shout you out there next up
honorable mention we got Marcus seam
uh with a little like
food processor thing and if you look
closely you can see each one of these
pieces of food are being upgraded and
it's fun to just watch all these take on
so the beer goes to like a martini it's
hard to see but fruit and vegetables to
go to some sort of as a chicken cube the
cube goes to a donut
yeah it's a nice little machine you put
together I thought this was awesome
uh next up honorable mention MDK I see
you
yes so you put together this awesome
scene here my only note for you is
um to to trim some of the fat like
there's uh I feel like we're waiting for
stuff to happen especially at like the
front end of things but once it gets
going it's super cool I love seeing this
thing transform
into a zombie compound
and of course they're like you know what
this is top secret y'all we gotta cut
the feed
so good shout outs to you MDK next up we
got noodle Chon
very simple
little breakdown you put together here
um I believe you took concept art uh or
heavily inspired by a certain artist's
concept for this weapon and uh you built
out each piece
and slapped them together in this cool
little video I just wish it was longer I
think that's the only thing
or if it was like an infinite Loop
that would be my only note but dude your
color palette is off the charts the way
you lit this
is so good so so good
um next up
I think this is second to last we have
swall
ow for that honorable mention now
this one this one came close to winning
I was just like confused this to like
what the heck this was even like what
what is going on here you we have
kangaroo like cyber kangaroos
like getting ready to race or something
like or they have dumbbells like they're
they're about to start working out but
why are they on
like Nutella and peanut butter I don't
know it looks photo real
um and
but it also looks like it was like Hey I
generated or something weird like it's
hard to tell it has a very unique look
to it
um
but like even the little baby kangaroos
in the pouch
are hilarious
it just this one made me laugh this one
had me asking a lot of questions
um good stuff and finally we have
maku
with this cool little laptop
transformation
laptop to a PC upgrade
and then back to a laptop this is like
really nice this is almost like I could
see this being on some sort of app like
loading you know or uh we're working on
your order you know kind of a thing
you really did a great job with this
it's very subtle or not subtle but very
simple
but super effective
so congratulations to the winners
to the honorable mentions and let's take
a look here real quick and see what the
new weekly challenge is
or this week bear with me here let me uh
get my screens and we got three screens
and a bunch of different programs it
looks like a experiment
is next
let's see here
oh no
weekly challenge
confirmed it's experiment so guys you
have a weak
starting yesterday to make a render
that
is inspired by The Prompt experiment so
dig in have fun with it
um
it's a good way to practice your art and
stay passionate and there are there's
never an excuse for running out of ideas
because I try and get you
uh as many ideas as possible
with these weekly challenges and it's
not just me I I can't take credit for it
we have an awesome Community we got the
patrons
um coming up with challenge prompts that
they're voted on by the community so the
patrons come up with three suggestions
for you on the weekly challenge and then
that goes to the entire server y'all can
vote on which one you want
um so we try and keep it open to the
community
um
so that is the stream y'all I'm chilling
with you guys for the next I don't know
10 minutes or so I'ma hop in with you
we're gonna do some q a
um and just just hang out
how are you guys doing did you guys
enjoy that one do you have any questions
for me
it's gonna be back
oh snap next week is the hundredth
challenge
experiment is challenge 99. dang we
gotta do something nice
what's up 80 from Malaysia what's going
on
thanks for hanging out with us here
we got 320 people chilling I appreciate
you guys hanging out with me
always a good time I hope you guys
learned a lot with this one too as soon
as the stream is wrapped I'm gonna go
back in and uh
add some chapters so you guys can go
back and watch
all these breakdowns
um I'll split it up for you make it easy
to watch it again
um so if you guys have any questions for
me please at me here in the chat so at
Punisher it'll allow me to
kind of pinpoint which ones are
questions for me and and what isn't
um Sino no there are no unreal users in
the top five we only got blender and uh
we got four blenders one c4d and then I
used Unreal Engine so my breakdown I'm
gonna be working on my breakdown
um it's gonna come out in I believe two
weeks from now I'm doing a full
breakdown of my scene how I created my
scene in Unreal Engine
um how I'm lighting how I'm using assets
how I'm making custom texture Maps like
all of it all we're getting into all of
it so I'm gonna do a nice little
breakdown for you guys
um in two weeks from now so look forward
to it
all right um
nor you're saying would you say that
with the number of submissions
increasing with every challenge would
you consider bumping up the number of
renders in the winners montage
um no
I don't think so because
10 I mean man okay so top 100 that's a
lot and I would rather have the top 100
just keep getting better the top 100 the
better you guys get the better the top
100 gets
um also with custom music it's really
difficult to write a lot
of music for these things like this last
one was ten and a half minutes worth of
custom music all written in about a
month if it goes out to 20 minutes it
just becomes impossible at that point it
becomes pricey like you know I gotta pay
for the music to be to be custom made
um
I don't have plans for doing a top 200
or anything
I think would just keep it simple top
100 it sounds nice and they're just
gonna keep getting better the better you
all get
um
and of course there's always gonna be
the all renders challenge too but who
knows in the future who who knows
um let's see oh man Albert okay so a
long time ago I think you talked about
making a video on file management when
working with 3D are you still planning
on making that I think it's an
incredible one to to finish it is a
beast of
of a video
um I interviewed everyone from people to
Ian Hubert to uh
uh shoot what's his name
freaking Andre LeBron thank you Andre
LeBron and like the people over at uh
action VFX like I hit up everybody I
could and asked them what their workflow
was on how to manage their files and how
to
work as efficiently as possible so
you're not digging through stuff and
wasting time
yeah I really want to put that out I
really do it's just
such an edit there's hours of footage I
have to dig through interviews and stuff
um and it has to kind of be written
Rewritten in the edit
so it's a process but yeah I think it's
an important one it's an important one
I'm planning to do it it'll be next year
but it's on the list
um solo ghost what am I working on
currently I'm working on the breakdown
for
um my moving meditations piece of art
all in Unreal Engine I'm gonna be
working on
um like I mentioned to you guys I was in
Virginia for camp mograph we were just
chilling on the beach with 3D artists
for like four to five days at a campsite
it was incredible
um I try and let you guys know when
tickets go on sale it's put together by
the mograph.com guys
um Camp mograph guys
and um
it's an incredible experience like if
you if you can come down to the States
for it next year please like try to come
down it's so good a great way to meet
people great way to take a break to
learn get inspired it's so good so while
I was there I was heavily inspired by a
moment we would have every single
uh evening we would watch the sunset
together as a whole group so I have a
render in mind that I want to create
um I believe in Unreal Engine it could
be Cinema 4D but that's next for me I'm
gonna create that environment I'm
excited about that I'm also digging
pretty heavily into AI
so I want to put out some AI tutorials I
think will be very very
um beneficial to the community
other than that
um getting ready for a little uh
I'm always trying to think of challenges
new challenges
and we do these big 3D Community
challenges once every six months roughly
two times a year
right but I have an idea that me and the
mods have been talking about trying to
figure out the best way to do it
um
I can't give you too much info now but
we are working towards putting together
a new type of challenge
um something that you could maybe work
on for a little bit longer than a month
and
it's gonna be super cool I can't wait to
see how it goes down so yeah working on
a little bit something like that
uh other than that you know that's kind
of my year you know um and then I'm
going to get into next year and plans
for next year and stuff
all right going down this list here I'm
looking at these at punishers
when do you find out the next big
challenge you find out the next big
challenge when it gets dropped that's
pretty much it if you're on the Discord
server that's the first place you're
gonna find out about the challenge
um
same on YouTube if you guys aren't
subscribed definitely do so
um it's the best way to find out about
these challenges but being on the
Discord got you we got you as well
um for the 3D weekly 3D challenge can
you submit a Photoshop based on the
prompt no we're we're trying to keep it
to 3D only
you know that's the focus
let's see let's go through
foreign
[Music]
you said you recently started learning
unreal without completing blender to its
full potential any advice or suggestions
well I'd say unreal and blender
go really well together so I wouldn't
say that it's it it's not like you
started eating a meal got halfway
through and switched to the next meal
it's not like that it's like you can
always come back and like that blender
will always be there for you it's not
like you have to move on and you're done
with it
blender and unreal go so well together
just like c4d and unreal go so well
together
um because so much of the things need to
be created so many of the assets need to
be created in blender animated in
blender
um
you know stuff like that and then that
comes over into Unreal Engine where you
kind of compile it together light it and
you have your real time scene
um
so I would say just keep learning what
you find to be fun
and that's going to take you a long way
and if you are just all about unreal
then go with unreal right now
you just don't want to stifle your
progress with indecision you don't want
to stop yourself be like oh what's what
should I do what should I do I should do
it's like you're scrolling through
Netflix for an hour and then you realize
oh I gotta go to bed I never figured out
what to watch
just learn something
go go where your heart is and then
you'll be good
lender ain't going nowhere
let's see
uh Diego have I ever animated and Maya
what do I think about it do I recommend
it I never have animated in Maya but I
heard the animation in Maya is like
super streamlined very easy a lot of
r d and time has gone into making that
program awesome because it is pretty
much industry standard
um when you're working at a studio is
Maya
um from what I've heard it does well
with like
having a
it supports a lot of different
departments
um
so
I know DreamWorks right so there's a
one of the guys wait sir Wade right he
has a YouTube channel sir Wade
and he taught Maya at DreamWorks and
another friend of mine Don Allen
Stevenson the Third
he did the same thing at at DreamWorks
taught Maya
um sir Wade has YouTube channel uh Don
Allen Stevenson the third has a YouTube
channel as well
um and I know that Sam at Rococo uses
Maya a lot
uh for like a lot of retargeting and
whatnot
and animating on top of mocap data and
cleaning up mocap data so it's
definitely something that I'm looking to
and I think at a certain point like
it'll be helpful I'm just not I hadn't
dug in yet
foreign
you want a recommendation on a random
non-vfx YouTube channel
hmm
shoot
well I think I gotta go to my like
subscriptions here and see
see what we're dealing with
um
non-v effects God this is a mess
wow YouTube needs to get their stuff
together this looks
this looks rough
hmm drumio I'm I love drums so drumio is
a great place to go if you're trying to
like learn how to play drums oh Adam
leall all right for cooking this dude
he's one of the bet he's like the
chillest dude
I've ever seen on YouTube Adam leall
that's a
d-a-m-l-i-a-w and he teaches you how to
make ramen like legit Ramen
yes it's called Ramen school
um and he goes into it it's like a
multi-day process to make legit Ramen he
also has uh fried rice Fridays he has
like all these traditional
um recipes he does a lot of Japanese
Cuisine so
um oyakodan which is uh chicken and egg
together with like a light teriyaki
sauce he teaches you how to make your
own teriyaki sauce it's so easy
um and there's like onion you chop The
Onion
kind of get it all going together
um and you got some like uh some chicken
broth
so good so good Adam Leal definitely
check him out
let's see who else we got here non
VFX related
um music I love me some music there's a
channel blue bear flutes I got my native
Flute from them and uh
yeah it's really cool teaches you how to
make flutes teaches you how to play
flutes
um hard is easy it's another Channel I'm
into because I love climbing and this
dude does a great great job at
explaining
how to train for climbs
um
uh different gear and techniques and
terminology hard is easy that's the
channel
shoot sotomante you got a good question
here man I'm going through all this
stuff
um
Olin Rogers freaking hilarious
love that dude
that's about it
when it comes to my subscriptions
on non-vfx stuff on YouTube
all right what else do we got
let's see I'll do a couple more
and then I'm gonna get some food y'all
I'm actually cooking oyakodan
uh after this
Adam leall's recipe
all right Monk
do you think AI will completely cut out
3D software or any software for that
matter in the next few years and
everything will be done a different way
question mark
I think AI is Gonna Change
our industry like crazy yes I do
um I heard the best talk ever
at half res in Chicago like three weeks
ago
um from the CEO or was he was the guy
who made School of motion I I'm blanking
on his name right now
but he had the best
talk on a ir and it was titled like
mograph is dead
long live mograph right
um and he was like look at this AI it's
crazy you know what it's doing like
we're all freaking out it's going to
take our jobs
and he was actually like no it's not
like it's going to empower more people
to create which is always a good thing
it's going to raise the bar globally for
everybody
um and he also talks about too like how
we've been in situations like this where
a cheap
easy access tool comes along
where all the people who created before
this tool are like no it's not legit if
you use this new tool because it's
easier and more people can access it
it's not legit you didn't have to learn
how to slave over like
frames and do all this animation and by
hand stuff if you don't know how to do
it the you know the real way then it
doesn't count if you do it with the new
way
and that happened with after effects
when After Effects came out this is all
part of his his talk he was saying how
like when after effects came along you
had these artists who are using flame
which is like a compositor and like paid
thousands of dollars for this like the
suite to get the hardware and then to
get the artists you were like so
specialized you came in and you know you
composited movies and you did your thing
but when After Effects came out it gave
everyone the ability to do what these
flame artists were doing and the flame
artists were like oh no our jobs our
jobs
and it just came down to the point where
it's like
we got into
an industry
that is constantly evolving and
constantly growing and if you're not
evolving and growing with the industry
you're going to be left behind and I
think a friend was talking about the ilm
documentary I hadn't seen it yet but he
was saying how like there is the
puppeteers right for the old Sci-Fi
movies horror movies they would make
these puppets and you know
that was their that was their career
that was their life
but then when like CG came along
half of them were like
screw that I'm not gonna do it in CG I'm
gonna do it the real way the way with
the puppets the way that I know how to
do it and then the other half were like
the 3D is amazing I'm gonna get into it
I'm gonna get good at it because that's
where the industry is going and they
just adapted with the times and they
they yeah they adapted with the times
they're smart they had to adapt and grow
with the technology
and those some of those people are some
of the best 3D artists nowadays the best
animators nowadays are the people from
the puppet puppet World way back in the
day
um when special effects were huge you
know back in the 80s
70s 80s
um
and like
it just comes down to adapting with what
we got so now we have ai right is AI
putting all of us out of place and I
think it just comes down to learning the
software getting good at it you can be
better it's not just typing a prompt
like you can get better at getting
better images
so what oh man I really wish I
remembered his name it's the guy who
started school of motion that's the guy
who was given this uh
his presentation and he was saying like
now anyone can make
the image like the work to produce an
image or even a video now because ai's
doing video
it's easier
so what becomes
valuable is the idea
how good is your idea
it comes down to that so you just gotta
get good just get good get good that's
what it comes down to
it is understanding that we got into an
industry that is constantly evolving and
upgrading and it's going to get faster
and faster and if you want to
you know be a part of this you're gonna
have to upgrade your toolkit and AI is
an undeniable part of the toolkit now so
I'm looking forward to
ways to use Ai and ways to implement it
and I want to do some videos on it
um I want to do some streams with AI I
want to really get into it after that
presentation that I heard at halfres in
Chicago which by the way come down next
year this was my first time there it was
awesome I want to try and be there next
year as well
um it's a one night meet up with
presentations
um
games like it's at a it's at a bar in
Chicago amazing
and uh I I was like man this
presentation changed my outlook on AI I
was pretty nervous about it I didn't
feel good about it I was kind of staying
away from it I'm like not taking it too
seriously
I get scared like part of me is scared
when like industry is moving on without
me
and I had this like guilty scared
feeling like
the less because I know I need I'm
procrastinating I know I need to get
into AI I just know it
and I'm lucky to have friends around me
who are like at the top right now the
top of AI right now Corridor put out an
awesome video like go check out that
video Corridor crew is their last video
on AI amazing
um
so I gotta get good I gotta step up I
can't be afraid of it I gotta dive in so
that would be my suggestion to you guys
is get into it do your research have fun
with it
oh and with that guys I think I'm gonna
call it I gotta make this oyakodon Adam
leall check out his YouTube channel
l-i-a-w Adam Leal check out his oyakodan
recipe it's delicious it's gonna be
making over the next couple hours but
y'all thank you so much for joining me
thank you sonamonte for hooking up the
live stream getting all of our guests
working
um
and uh thank you to our guests thank you
to you guys for joining me thank you to
everybody
thank you for everybody
all right y'all um I think that's about
it
have a good one I'll see you uh two
weeks from now all right two weeks from
now we're back to regularly
right regular regularly scheduled
programming
it's a video every two weeks all right
so I'm doing that art breakdown for my
movie meditations piece of art all in
Unreal Engine
I'll see you guys soon have a good one
later peace
[Music]
foreign
[Music]